thank you
foreign
good morning and welcome to the first
day of the main hearings of the covid-19
UK public inquiry
I shall start by hearing opening
submissions from Council to the inquiry
and from the core participants
and then evidence in module one covering
resilience and preparedness for the
pandemic
as people arrived at the hearing center
today they found a dignified vigil of
bereaved family members holding
photographs of their loved ones
their grief was obvious to all
it is on their behalf and on behalf of
the millions who suffered and continue
to suffer in different ways as a result
of the pandemic that I intend to answer
the following three questions
was the UK properly prepared for a
pandemic
was the response to it appropriate and
can we learn lessons for the future
to conduct the kind of thorough
investigation the people of the United
Kingdom deserve takes time and a great
deal of preparation
an extraordinary amount of work has been
done to get us to this point
I wish to commend all those involved the
inquiry team both Secretariat and legal
the core participants the witnesses and
the material providers
it will it has been and it will remain a
huge task and I am acutely conscious of
the burden I have placed on everyone by
the ambitious timetable I have set
but if I am to achieve my aim of making
timely recommendations that may say
lives and reduce suffering in the future
I had no choice
my plan as people now know is to publish
reports as we go along
so that when the hearings for this
module finish work will begin on
preparing the report for this module
when that report is ready it will be
published
in the meantime the other module teams
and I will be working on the next
modules
I have promised many times that those
who suffered hardship and loss are and
will always be at the heart of the
inquiry
and I have done my very best within the
constraints upon me of time resources
and my terms of reference to fulfill
that promise
I know that there are those who feel
that the inquiry has not sufficiently
recognized their loss or listened to
them in the way that they feel
appropriate
but I hope that they will better
understand as the inquiry progresses the
very difficult balance I have had to
strike
I hope they will understand when they
see the results of the work we are doing
that I am listening to them
their loss will be recognized
they will be able to contribute to the
inquiry
by describing their experiences at
community events or sharing their story
online or on the phone
some will contribute by giving evidence
at the hearings and representatives of
each of the four buried family groups
will be called in this module
some will contribute by helping us
design further panels of the tapestry
four panels of which are here today
we're not the first to decide that the
pandemic should be commemorated and I'm
happy to acknowledge the excellent work
done by others for example the covid
Chronicles
so many people died and so many people
suffered it is only right that we find
various ways to commemorate them and
their experience
the way in which the bereaved and those
who suffered can contribute to the
inquiry is by agreeing to talk about
their experience on our impact films
in a moment we're going to watch the
first of them
in which people from across the four
nations of the United Kingdom talk about
the devastating impact the pandemic has
had on them and on their loved ones
bereavement is a major theme of this
first film but future films will cover a
wider range of experiences
the film is extraordinarily moving
it involves people talking in very
explicit terms about their suffering and
their loss
in a way that will bring back very
difficult memories for many people
I want to thank everyone who agreed to
be filmed as part of this including
those not featured in this first film
I can only imagine how difficult it must
have been for them to relive those
experiences in front of a camera
but please believe it was worthwhile
you have recorded your experience for
posterity and alerted me to issues that
I need to explore
if you do not want to view the film
right now there will be an opportunity
to leave the room
the ushers will show you to the
refreshments area the three screens
there will not be showing the film and
someone will call you back in once it is
finished
if you're watching the live stream You
may wish to turn off YouTube the
duration is approximately 17 minutes
emotional support is available to anyone
here at the hearing center for those
watching online there's a list of
numbers to call on the inquiry website
once the film begins to play a warning
will be displayed for 30 seconds before
the first images appear
once the video has been played we will
reassemble and I will ask Mr Hugo Keith
King's Council cancel to the inquiry to
make his opening statement
so with those who would like to leave
the hearing room now do so
foreign
please
when the covid-19 pandemic started it
was I guess something that that took us
all by surprise it was the beginning of
the pandemic I contracted covid while
working on the ortho geriatrics Ward
where we look after patients my wife had
um
COPD one morning the oxygen level seemed
to be quite low so I found a doctor and
they said it was best to take it a a e
they took it in
in chapter when we lock down at work you
know I said we need to take this
seriously to my chief executive
we're going to know people that die from
these but never thought for a minute of
being my dad and my sister five days
apart
it happened all very quickly within
seven days my mum was gone
we missed it
we missed it completely
for the few days that Mom was not well
my father died aged 86 in a care home
from covid
we were told he was going to die
imminently and the only thing we could
do is be outside his window
in the icy Terrain
my mum was um one of the first in
Northern Ireland today
and she died just at the start of
lockdown in the 24th of March 2020. mom
was our world
my dad unfortunately ended up uh in
hospital
um in early January 20 2021 and I think
because we weren't really there we
weren't able to really influence
um the care in the way that we'd done
previously where I think our input had
made a huge difference to the outcome
well I was a 57 year old Taxi Driver
um caught covered in the back of his
taxi he was blue couldn't breathe his
wife's a nurse so she knew exactly what
was needed
five weeks
because you see your
nothing maybe it wasn't every hour every
hour every day
for the consultant it's the only update
you had on them
um we lost my 67 year old father to
hospital acquire covert on the 23rd of
December 2020. the circumstances
surrounding the lead up to his death and
his eventual demise will haunt us for
the rest of our lives at the end of
anyone's time the most you can hope is
to give your loved one a good death and
we will forever carry the guilt that our
daddy was denied that my daughter said
that her dad wasn't sounding really well
on the telephone and she wanted to go
down to see him
my daughter went down there she said he
wasn't eating he wasn't doing anything
he just couldn't breathe properly he
couldn't talk and when we we called the
ambulance they were really nice they
came up and they tested his oxygen level
and they said he had to go hospital he
kept saying no they kept saying yes
they tested him and they said it's
definitely covered
I got a call from the home to say my dad
wasn't well was sending him to hospital
today and I took a big part in my dad's
care
so I said okay I'll wait for the
ambulance I told so when the ambulance
came
and I held him in my arms and I said Dad
you've got to be the strongest you've
ever been it's a terrible disease he's
out there and I think he should have
been a strong better be and I
can't come in this time and he just said
okay
and then the following day the nurse
came by that time my mom's conditioner
deteriorated quite bad and
it turned out that my mom was actually
suffering from covet and was already in
a very bad way after seven days I
started
spitting blood and I called ambulance
services I went to the hospital and
immediately I was saying by the
consultant and the results were not
looking very good at all I was taken to
ICU and intubated
and after that I woke up after six weeks
in the middle of June I was so unwell
that three times they had tried to stop
treatment and keep me comfortable
but slowly and steadily I improved end
of August 2021 I was able to go back to
work she clearly wanted to come home and
I said well you've been tested twice
I'll come and get your roof so I went to
go to but that night
and I awoke to see her sitting on the
edge of the bed and she couldn't stop
coughing she was coughing coughing off
the ward rang to see that last test
came back positive
hospital because something really simple
like our Warframe levels were too high
and unfortunately she inquired covered
in there they told me mom was doing well
I rang up to find out how she was doing
they couldn't give me any information I
said but I can't get up so you have to
tell me
and I see somebody being touched later
on
and then just after the Prime Minister
me at his lockdown to speech I got a
phone call the same one wasn't going to
make it
I ask could any of us be there
and they said no
the next 12 hours were the hardest 12
hours of my life
the impression I got was that he was he
was obviously unwell but that he was
relatively stable and then on the Friday
we got called in
to say look he's um is is kind of
basically at the end he's really
deteriorated overnight and now you
should come in so we we rushed in and
but by then it was too late he'd already
by the time we got paid already and
passed so that was
yeah of course it was a massive shock
he was calling me by my pet member she
normally does says
can we go to the hospital tomorrow
and I said no mama
we have to go
we have to go now we can't wait until
tomorrow
we waited and waited and waited
and then
the phone call came
and it was a doctor a consultant a
doctor
and called and I actually rushed because
I thought oh the economy is likely
probably about the the review for my mom
and then
she just announced that oh I'm sorry to
to tell you about your mom just passed
away
I'm expecting to go there and see her
and discuss what you know next
treatments would be I know that
and she just said your mom has just
passed away
so I was ringing four times a day and
seeing how he was and then on the Friday
they said he wasn't well it was
obviously was dying
and I stayed with him till five o'clock
the next morning when he passed away
and then I left my dad
and my sister had a bit of a cough I
text my sister's partner she knew it was
in hospital dad has passed away and tell
her I'll be up at dinner time
and he ran me about 10 minutes later and
he said she was unresponsive I've called
an ambulance
So within half an hour of me being home
and even my dad my sister was being
rushed to hospital unresponsive
and then all week they were saying she's
not going to make the night she's not
going to make the night and then I said
can you try and
call us then if you know you can't leave
this time to get us up there we don't
want to die alone she was only 54.
and she died alone
five days after my third
you know it took so long to get a doctor
to talk to you as to what's happening is
he getting any better is he getting any
worse and then we got the call that
they're taking him to intensive care and
my heart
sank
they said they were going to put him
into an induced coma
and then we got the call
about 11 51.
to say that he had passed
now
my anger is I don't know what really
happened what happened between him just
feeling Awards with other people that
had covered to then being transferred to
ICU what was it
I don't have these answers as yet
and this is frustrating for me
I could just imagine
mommy on her own
you know what was it like for what was
our last 12 hours like all sort of
images and thoughts of mommy wearing my
head you know
about how she had protected us
for all our lives and in the final hours
when she really needed us
none of us could be there the phone call
came through to say that she'd passed
and
um I asked the nurse about her
belongings and she said um
I'm sorry everything will be incinerated
you know so mommy's me glasses
all her 90s and dress and kinds were all
going to be incinerated
I woke up and I was really really ill
um
terrible like
Mr phone 999 and I can remember opening
the door to paramedics
um and then the next thing I knew I woke
up in the world
anyway a couple of days after she's she
did pass away suddenly I'm on my own
um we were caught in full
and married for 48.
and so this affected me a lot so greatly
this I'm on my own now
that's
arms
reaching towards me
to help him and I couldn't
it's not really an ideal way to say
goodbye to your father or anyone
and because I live alone and all my
families abroad I told them not to come
back because it was locked down this sat
and it would have just been a nightmare
so I arranged his funeral alone
for what it was the funeral there I
think there were 15 people there
I didn't hug anybody from
hearing that was going to die
I'm hearing that dad was going to die he
was so ill
right through till past the funeral I
didn't hug anybody
it was a frightening time it was a very
very lonely time grief is lonely anyway
but grief that of that at that time was
so compounded by the absence of comfort
of closeness of other humans
I used to be in there so I know what a
good death is
and I wasn't able to give Dad that
it was hard
it was hard for so many people
I think everybody suffered somehow
in Northern Ireland uh awake is a very
important part of the grieving process
that didn't happen I don't go to the
cemetery now because when I go to the
cemetery I see
the red my tip
see the man in their white suits and
their masks I see
them putting their hand up telling me I
can't go towards the grave side I relive
that I hear them tell me our time is up
you know our time was up we all had to
walk off individually Uncle home to our
own houses
there was no coming together
my mum didn't get a celebration of her
life
Anna's a daughter
that makes me feel I Fielder
the worst impact this had was on my
Elder frail elderly parents who lived in
India and she my mother passed away in
2021 and my father followed her in 2022.
so mildness had such a
severe impact
on on my family on my parents and I
always feel if this hadn't happened my
parents might still be there now
our family were denied all the usual
bereavement rituals um which has left us
uh with the guilt that we couldn't pay
tribute to your father
um that those loved him couldn't show
their respect it also left us as a
family very isolated for example it was
six months after daddy died that my
mother first got a human hug
eat people if funeral
my mother 83 year old two years
certainly deathly silence
um and the next thing we hear is this
old
steel rattle tattoo coming down the the
crematorium and everyone is turned
around and looked and there is my
brother getting rolled down in his 30
year olds steel trolley the noise I'll
never forget that noise I'll never
forget and that was it I mean people can
read things without textbook do I know
if you need to know how we feel nobody
until actually if you're sitting in my
shoes right now then you you'll be able
to say and whatever I know but nobody
knows how I feel but life's are just
broken
never we try and go anywhere each
through each day you know what I mean
but
I've lost everything
you know it's just not what you expect
it's terrible when somebody that you
love dies but
to not help them make their final
Journey perfect and lovely really hurts
and they can't give them the same enough
that they deserve already out it's
something I will never ever get over
and the time they needed me most I
wasn't there
and that all and I feel guilty about
that
even though it wasn't my fault
you couldn't be there with them to hold
their hands
you couldn't see them when they died
you can't really organize a proper
funeral you can't gather together and
moan and be with other people
you're just alone
I still suffer from anxiety I still wear
my mask Everywhere I Go
all I can say is we you don't know when
it's going to
get better we learn to live with it but
you don't know when it's going to get
better
it's left me having a well both myself
and my mum with
you know a great amount of guilt and
Trauma about and pain particularly about
what happened
in in the Caribbean culture I've got to
say when there's a funeral you're
talking about hundreds of people easily
they were telling us 20 people could
attend a funeral we gave the best
send-off we could
but that's not the way he would have
been sent off on a normal day no way
they had the bodies in bags that you
couldn't even give them an
family in an outfit they said they
they're in a zipped bag and it's got
some lock on it and they're not allowed
to break the lock
I'm angry I need questions answered
I'm just still hurt and I'm still upset
and it's been a couple years now
and we're still upset
and it's not going to go away just like
that
the grief I have is my love
and I just need to find a way to tell
them look I think it's a very important
part of History
and history has to reflect the truth
of what happened to families like May
and I am so aware that Society are so
tired of the whole thing
for us those missing parts they're there
for a reason and the great process
and there's no way to navigate around
those things you have to go through
those unbe and denied those we have it's
a vital part of us being able to move on
and ultimately in order for us to move
on we need to know what lessons will be
learned and the future Generations will
be safeguarded from the heartache that
we have had to suffer
I hope that those who had to leave the
room will be able to recover as soon as
we're able to
reassemble which will do so could we
send a message to them please ask them
if they wish to come back in
foreign
I'm sorry to all of those who found that
film particularly distressing I think it
was distressing for everybody but I'm
sure
especially so for you so I'm sorry about
that
Mr Keith
my lady
we will likely never know how
severe acute respiratory syndrome
coronavirus II
more commonly known as SARS Co V2 the
virus that caused the covid-19 pandemic
was first transmitted to the human race
perhaps it came from Farm wild animals
that were transported to and then sold
in the live Wet Market in Wuhan the
capital city of Hubei Province China in
fact in Market workers and customers
some have suggested it came from a leak
of coronavirus specimens being
transported to or stored at the Wuhan
Institute of virology
we will also likely never know when the
first human infection with SARS cov2
occurred
minute retrospective examination by
scientists of how the genetic sequencing
of the virus altered over time
suggests that the dates of its emergence
could have been any time between
mid-october 2019 and mid-December 2019.
certainly the first reported case
reported after the event was the 12th of
December of 2019.
but my lady for this inquiries purposes
this knowledge does not matter
what we do know is that the United
Kingdom as with the rest of the world
was struck by a major pandemic
as with all pandemics the covid-19
pandemic left in its wake death misery
and incalculable loss
as the impact film that we have just
seen in which we heard from just a tiny
proportion of those whose loved ones had
died demonstrates so Pony of me
the pandemic did not just alter
fundamentally how modern societies
across the globe functioned but ended
and changed lives on a scale unseen in
modern history
no inquiry however large or however long
could possibly inquire into all aspects
of a pandemic that wrought such damage
and your inquiry does not seek to do so
you have instead determined that it will
focus on those areas of the pandemic and
the United Kingdom's response to it that
have caused the greatest public concern
and where there may be a need in the
public interest to make urgent
recommendations so that we may be better
prepared in the event of the next
national civil emergency to before us
that module starts today module one
it commences that process
it investigates what the state of the
whole country's emergency preparedness
response and resilience structure and
systems were when the pandemic struck in
January 2020
. my lady I therefore need to set out
the briefest of chronologies
because it's important to appreciate and
understand before we hear the evidence
concerning the decade before the
pandemic what the reality was in January
so
in late December 2019 a cluster of cases
of pneumonia of an unknown origin was
detected in Wuhan city Hubei Province
China
a new strain of coronavirus was
subsequently isolated on the 7th of
January 2020 it was identified as SARS
cov2
on the 10th of January in the United
Kingdom the Department of Health and
Social care the dhsc published guidance
for health professionals on the
assessment and management of suspected
United Kingdom cases
on the 21st of January the World Health
Organization published its novel
coronavirus
2019 n kovi situation report one
this is the date in fact at which the
period covered by module 1 ends
the situation report one recorded that
as of the 20th of January
282 confirmed cases of 2019 n COV had
been reported from four countries
including China Thailand Japan
and the Republic of Korea
on the 30th of January 2020 the second
meeting of the international Health
regulations emergency Committee of the
World Health Organization declared a
public health emergency of international
concern but it's notable that the
recommended no travel or trade
restrictions
the virus and the disease covid-19
spread rapidly
the United Kingdom's scientific Advisory
Group for emergencies Sage convened for
the first time on the 22nd of January
and the Civil contingencies committee
Cobra met on the 24th of January 2020.
the foreign Commonwealth office issued
its first travel advice on the 23rd of
January
the first two cases of covid-19 in
England were confirmed on the 30th of
January
and on the same day NHS England declared
a serious level 4 incident
by the end of January it was becoming
apparent and my lady the degree to which
it was apparent is of course a matter
for module two
that the disease was a respiratory
disease which was asymptomatic meaning
that a person infected by the virus
might not show any symptoms of it and
for which there was no ready test no
antiviral medicine no immunity and no
vaccine
on the 15th of February France recorded
the first official death in Europe from
covert 19.
by late February the number of cases
outside China had increased 13 fold and
the number of affected countries have
tripled
a worldwide Public Health Emergency was
underway
although a pandemic was not in fact
declared by the World Health
Organization until the 11th of March
the first positive cases in Wales and
Northern Ireland were reported on the
28th of February and in Scotland on the
1st of March although that case related
to an outbreak that had occurred a few
days earlier a conference that had
occurred on a few days earlier on the
26th and 27th of February
the first death in the United Kingdom a
woman in her 70s was confirmed on the
2nd of March
on the 3rd of March the dhsc the
Scottish government the Welsh government
and the Department of Health in Northern
Ireland published a coronavirus covid-19
action plan setting out how they plan to
tackle the coronavirus outbreak
based on the experience of dealing with
other infectious diseases and the
influenza pandemic preparedness work
that had been carried out the plan
stated that the United Kingdom was well
prepared to respond in a way that
offered substantial protection to the
public
whether that was actually the case will
be examined in module one
and of course that is why module one in
terms of preparedness in terms of the
response that was expected
that is the focus of your examination
and even at this stage before hearing
the evidence
it is apparent that we might not have
been very well prepared at all
on the 4th of March the dhse in England
announced a campaign focusing on the
importance of washing hands and washing
hands for 20 seconds using soap and
water or hand sanitizer on the 6th of
March the United Kingdom government
announced significant additional funding
for Rapid diagnostic tests and for the
international fund into vaccine research
on the 11th of March the then chance of
exchequer Richie sunac MP announced a
package of emergency support including
the establishment of a 5 billion pound
emergency fund to support the NHS and
other public services in England and
additional NHS funding measures for
additional access to statutory sick pay
contributory employment support
allowance a hardship fund for local
councils and business Interruption loans
on the 12th of March the then prime
minister Boris Johnson MP announced that
the United Kingdom had moved into the
delay phase of the coronavirus action
plan
my lady you will recall that he informed
the country that many more families were
going to lose loved ones before their
time and he announced that as part of
the attempt to delay the spread of
covid-19 anyone with symptoms however
mild should stay at home for at least
seven days
it is absolutely clear now with
hindsight that the disease was spiraling
out of control
but to what extent was that possibility
foreseen planned for and guarded against
how ready were the Public Public Health
structures to deal with this possibility
the reality was that the United Kingdom
government announced it would stop all
Community testing for covid-19 and focus
instead on testing people in hospitals
and protecting health workers as it
moved from the contained phase to the
delay phase
so it's clear that the system had not
adequately foreseen and prepared for the
need for Mass testing in the event of a
non-influenza pandemic
for a flu pandemic of course you're most
likely to show symptoms
you know you have a bug you go home
possibly to bed and you try not to pass
it on and tests aren't needed
on the 13th of March the then Welsh
Minister for Health and Social Services
Vaughn getting Ms announced the
suspension of a number of NHS services
to allow for services and beds to be
relegated and for staff to be redeployed
and retrained in priority areas
on the 16th of March the number of
deaths in the United Kingdom Rose to 55.
with
1543 confirmed cases
but the likely number of infected cases
was probably over ten thousand
there was no antiviral medicine
and no National pandemic flu service to
prescribe it
for the simple reason that covid-19 was
not an influenza virus
the United Kingdom government commenced
daily press conferences
the Prime Minister announced anyone with
a high temperature or a new and
continuous cough should stay at home for
14 days and not go out even to buy food
or Essentials
the country was told to stop
non-essential contact with others and to
stop all unnecessary travel
to start working from home where they
possibly could
and to avoid pubs clubs theaters and
other such social venues
the same day the department for business
energy and Industrial strategy
issued a statement calling for
businesses to support it by supplying
ventilators and ventilated components
across the United Kingdom
my lady you have directed that we ask to
what extent had the system envisaged and
prepared for the need for Mass provision
of personal protective equipment
on the 17th of March the chancellor
announced 330 billion pounds worth of
government-backed loans and 20 billion
pounds in tax cuts and grants
the foreign Commonwealth office advised
against all non-essential international
travel France imposed a nationwide
lockdown
the then first minister of Scotland
Nicholas sturgeon MSP made a statement
to the Scottish Parliament setting out
the stringent steps that were required
to be taken
the NHS England chief executive then Sir
Simon Stevens and the NHS England Chief
Operating Officer directed the NHS in
England to take measures to redirect
staff and resources to free up inpatient
and critical care capacity
these included the postponement of
non-all non-urgent elective operations
the Urgent discharge of all Hospital
inpatients who were medically fit to
leave and the block buying of capacity
in independent hospitals
what's this need for surge capacity
something that had been adequately
prepared for
on Wednesday the 18th of March the then
Secretary of State for Education sir
Gavin Williamson MP announced the
closure for the end of that week of
schools other than for children of
critical workers and vulnerable children
exams and assessments were later
canceled
Scottish first Minister the Welsh
Minister for Education Kirsty Williams
Ms and the first in Deputy first
ministers for Northern Ireland baroness
Arlene Foster MLA and Michelle O'Neill
MLA made similar announcements
but how developed were those plans for
school closures
on the 19th of March the Department of
Health and Social Security and the
ministry of housing communities and
local government provided further
details of how a 5 billion pound support
package would be given to local
authorities the defense secretary Ben
Wallace MP announced that up to 20 000
mod and service Personnel would be
placed on standby to support public
services including by way of driving
oxygen tankers around the United Kingdom
on Friday the 20th of March the
chancellor announced the coronavirus job
retention screen scheme and payments of
Grants back dated to the 1st of March of
up to 80 percent of furloughed workers
salaries
my lady cafes pubs and restaurants were
requested to be closed from that night
and nightclubs theaters gyms and Leisure
centers as soon as they reasonably can
in separate televised addresses
the then first minister of Scotland and
the first minister of Wales Mark
Drakeford Ms made similar Appeals
at 5 pm on that Sunday Public Health
England figures showed that there were 5
683 cases of covert in the United
Kingdom and 281 deaths
at that time the data referred only to
deaths in hospitals and didn't even
include deaths in the community in care
homes or in hospices
there'd been a rise of 48 deaths since
the previous day 37 in England seven in
Wales three in Scotland and one in
Northern Ireland
the weekly provisional figures for
deaths registered in England and Wales
with covid-19 as an underlying or
contributory cause calculated by the
office for National statistics was 103
for the week ending the 20th of March
and 539 for the week ending the 27th of
March
on Monday the 23rd of March we will
recall that the Prime Minister announced
severe restrictions on the entirety of
the United Kingdom in what became known
as the first national lockdown
on the 24th of March the Senate the
Welsh Parliament agreed to a legislative
consent motion on the coronavirus bill
on the 25th of March the coronavirus Act
was passed by the United Kingdom
Parliament and received Royal ascent
it had passed through all stages in the
House of Commons procedure in a single
day
and then on the 26th of March the
lockdown regulations were introduced
the health protection coronavirus
restrictions England regulations were
introduced by way of a statutory
instrument made by the Secretary of
State Matt Hancock Member of Parliament
using emergency Powers available to him
under the public health control and
disease act 1984 and the regulations
came into effect the moment that they
were made at 1pm on the same day
analogous coronavirus restrictions
regulations were made in Scotland and
Wales but the Scottish ministers and the
Welsh ministers
on the 28th of March Health protection
coronavirus restrictions regulations
were also made by the Department of
Health in Northern Ireland
I mentioned my lady the various
regulatory structures because one of the
work streams that had been progressed in
the Years leading up to the pandemic was
one of working on a pandemic Bill a
draft pandemic Bill to cover for the
eventuality of a pandemic striking the
United Kingdom
but in the reality the lockdown
regulations that were made in England
were made under a 1984 act the public
health controller diseases act in
Scotland under the coronavirus act and
in Northern Ireland under in 1967 piece
of legislation
that day the 26th of March the daily
death toll went up by 115.
the pandemic had the country in its grip
almost every era of public life across
all four nations including education
work travel the majority of public
services and family life were adversely
affected
the hospitality retail travel and
tourism arts and culture and the sport
and legislators effectively ceased even
places of worship closed
my lady as you know for very many what
they had to deal with went far beyond
the curtailment of their normal lives
and involved bereavement serious illness
deprivation mental illness exposure to
violence at home terrible Financial loss
loneliness and many other forms of
suffering
Health and Social care workers the
police and Emergency Services transport
workers teachers and other key workers
continued however in their places of
work
and they put their own lives on the line
in terms of their safety
the months and years that followed
we all recall
saw death and illness on an
unprecedented scale
but I don't need to set out even in
outline the events that followed the
lifting of the first lockdown the
further lockdowns the local restrictions
the gradual differences of approach
between the United Kingdom the devault
administrations and finally the root out
of the pandemic afforded
of the gift of vaccines
that is because for the purposes of this
module the state of preparedness must be
measured against the reality of when the
pandemic first struck January 2020.
it's my solemn duty to record that
government figures state that up to the
12th of May 2023 in England
there have been 192
231 deaths where covid-19 was recorded
on the death certificate
Scotland the figure is
17603 in Wales it is 11 848 and in
Northern Ireland
5295 making a total across the United
Kingdom of 226
977 lives
my lady by the measure of excess deaths
or excess mentality that is to say the
number of deaths from all causes over
and above what would be expected under
normal conditions have the pandemic not
occurred so capturing not only confirmed
deaths but also covid-19 deaths that
were not correctly diagnosed or reported
as well as other causes that are
attributable to the pandemic the figures
are likely to be higher still
research reveals that mortality rates
were significantly higher among people
with pre-existing conditions such as
dementia and Alzheimer's disease heart
disease high blood pressure and diabetes
shockingly
mortality was 2.6 Times Higher in the
most deprived than the least deprived
tenth of areas
people from some ethnic minority groups
had a significantly higher risk of being
infected by covid-19 and also from dying
from it
covid-19 mortality during the pandemic
was highest in people from the
Bangladeshi Pakistani and black
Caribbean communities
and mortality rates were higher among
people with a self-reported disability
or a learning disability
and so the big question for module one
is to what extent were those terrible
outcomes either foreseen or capable of
mitigation
my lady the pandemic has had profound
financial and economic consequences
to put National Health Systems under
enormous and continuing pressure
the impact on the Health Care Systems
its operations its waiting lists and on
elective care has been immense
millions of patients have either not
sought or received treatment and the
backlog has now reached historic levels
jobs and businesses have been destroyed
and livelihoods were taken away
the pandemic disrupted the education of
children and young people put Children
at Risk
and has left us with an enduring concern
that the pandemic further disparities in
attainment and development
the pandemic impacted the most
disadvantaged communities in society all
the more both in terms of the
consequences of getting the virus and in
terms of the steps taken to combat the
virus
societal damage in terms of the
exacerbation of inequalities and the
denial of access to opportunity has been
widespread
its impact will be felt for decades to
come
my lady the emergence of this natural
disaster could not have been avoided
but the key issue is whether that impact
that I have described was inevitable
were those terrible consequences
inexorable or were they avoidable or
capable of mitigation
starting point for your inquiry is that
whilst we may not know the moment that
this virus came into existence or how
exactly it made its way into the human
race we do know that the possibility of
a pandemic had been foretold and thought
about
indeed it had long been assessed by
planners that there was a significant
risk of a non-influenza pandemic and an
even greater risk of a flu pandemic
such risks were assessed and thought
about and planned for and prepared for
and written about
the Department's bodies agencies
Services responders and Personnel who
make up the United Kingdom's emergency
preparedness resilience and response
structures
EP RR structure
the first major acronym to which is my
unhappy duty to refer in in an area
Infested by acronyms
but fundamentally in relation to
significant aspects of the covid-19
pandemic
we were taken by surprise
huge
urgent
and complex policy decisions were
required to be taken in relation to
shielding
employment support managing disruption
to schools borders
lockdowns
and
non-pharmaceutical interventions
restrictions social restrictions
and equally importantly
the profoundly unequal impact of the
pandemic on the vulnerable and the
marginalized
few of those areas were anticipated let
alone considered in detail
my lady no amount of foresight or
planning can guarantee that a country
will not make mistakes when a disease
strikes but that does not mean that we
should not strive to be as ready as we
sensibly can be
no country can be perfectly prepared
but it can certainly be underprepared
and so it is to the adequacy and
sufficiency of those structures the
plans
steps taken to prepare and the degree to
which the country was resilient that is
to say able to respond and bounce back
that this first phase of the covert
inquiry turns its attention
module one will ask were the right eprr
structures in place the right procedures
the right plans was the system of
central devolved regional and local
government response available and ready
to go
did Civil contingency planners think
carefully enough about the risks of a
pandemic and how they could best prepare
for the crises which might develop from
those risks
module one will look at whether the eprr
system or was effective and practical
that the bodies and structures that
populated were fit for purpose and not
duplicative or obsolete
we will ask whether the system was
designed to work well under pressure
whether it gave responders
nationally and locally the proper tools
to respond with
we want to know whether the policy
documents and planning guidance were
useful
and not tarnished with bureaucracy or
prescriptive over management or jargon
most of the evidence over the next six
weeks will be concerned with those
issues
my lady standing back
there can however be no proper scrutiny
of the pandemic planning with which of
course you are primarily concerned
without a simultaneous detailed
examination of the actual civil
emergency structures upon which pandemic
planning rests
because pandemic planning is of course
just a feature of the wider civil
emergency structure
and so my lady the inquiry will be
looking at whether as a nation we were
sufficiently resilient
resilience is related to capacity and
concerns the ability of a country to
resist absorb and recover from shock
the ability to recover
closely connected to the general health
and wealth of the country as a whole
it's just for this reason the part of
the module as well as later modules in
your inquiry which will focus
specifically on inequalities we'll
explore what state the nation was in as
we entered the pandemic
did the high levels of heart disease
diabetes respiratory illness and obesity
render us more vulnerable
had there been a Slowdown in health
Improvement in the decade before
had health inequalities widened
did emergency planning sufficiently
account for pre-existing health and
Society inequalities deprivation
structural racism and other forms of
discrimination which undoubtedly exist
in society
as for wealth
it is self-evident that the capacity of
any country's Public Health Care and
social Care Systems to be able to cope
with the pandemic is constrained by
funding and therefore you need to
inquire how well-funded with the United
Kingdom's Health structures to what
degree of our Public Services especially
those of Health and Social care suffered
from under investment
how well resourced with United Kingdom's
Public Health structures
my lady these questions must be asked
this is not because it lies in the power
of your inquiry to resolve them
the inquiry plainly cannot of itself
bring about General improvements in
Health social care or public services
let alone direct that they be made
the questions must be asked because I
have no doubt that if you conclude that
as a country we were insufficiently
resilient
and that in future different political
and financial choices may have to be
made in order to render us better able
to withstand a System Shock you will
want to say so
but the need for all these questions is
obvious
first
the bereaved and those who otherwise
suffered of whom there are very many in
number are entitled to know if anything
could have been done to prevent their
loss or reduce their suffering
second
if we were shocked by the outbreak of
covid-19 History suggests we should not
have been
epidemics that is to say the occurrence
of a disease in a population at a level
that is significantly above the Baseline
level occur frequently
they can come on extraordinarily rapidly
and spread very quickly
they kill large numbers of people
pandemics whilst rarer are not new
ever since humans have walked on this
Earth pandemic disease the Black Death
play cholera
typhoid yellow fever influenza and Ebola
has walked with us
and scientists are clear that there is
an ever-increasing risk of pandemics in
the future
it's from animals zoonotic diseases pose
a Perpetual threat
a large proportion of those viruses
which infect mammals are capable of
infecting humans and many of them have
been associated with human deaths
at the same time
diseases are becoming more prevalent and
are being spread wider and faster on
account of globalization and
urbanization
so it's vital that International
surveillance and alert systems work
effectively
furthermore
terrible though it is to acknowledge
the rate in the United Kingdom at which
covid-19 generally killed those persons
who were confirmed or been infected with
it
the case fatality rate
was relatively low around one percent
the 1918
H1N1 flu pandemic was worse
its case fatality rate was around two
and a half to six percent
caused a massive number of deaths
worldwide
the estimates of death ranged in that
pandemic from Seventeen and a half
million to a hundred million
the case fatality rates of other
diseases such as fair and kreutzfeld
Jacob disease Ebola and smallpox were
also much higher than sales Co V2
significantly the case fatality rate of
MERS the Middle East Respiratory
Syndrome coronavirus the disease from
Camels that erupted in 2012 in the
Kingdom of Saudi Arabia was about 34.3
percent
SARS severe recuper Respiratory Syndrome
co-v1 the earlier coronavirus pandemic
in 2002 was around 9.6 percent
the relatively mild swine flu in 2009 to
10 about which we'll hear a considerable
amount of evidence in due course
was less than naught Point naught one
percent
what is critical therefore is
transmissibility
the more infectious the disease is the
more people are infected and the greater
number of people that will die
so the disease which poses the greatest
risk to human life
is the one that is both highly
infectious or transmissible and once
transmitted severe or deadly
and at the moment there are two notable
subtypes of Avian Influenza or bird flu
that are prevalent
both have extremely high case fatality
rates
fortuitously they haven't yet sustained
human to human transmission let us hope
they never do but the possibility cannot
be ruled out
which of course adds an even greater
impetus for the need to ensure that our
citizens of preparedness are ready
my lady the module is ambitious in terms
of its scope
the documentary material which it
encompasses
he is vast
but there's a limit
and I need to make plain what those
limits are
first module one is not an inquiry into
all aspects of the United Kingdom's
emergency planning systems it's only an
inquiry into those parts of the general
structures as is necessary to enable you
to answer the questions were the
structures and symptoms ready for the
pandemic that struck and how can we make
them better ready for next time
secondly module one has a time frame and
I've already referred to the second date
the 20th the end date the 21st of
January 2020 when the situation report 1
was issued by the World Health
Organization
it is beyond the ability of your inquiry
to go back before June 2009
which was when the World Health
Organization announced that scientific
criteria for an influenza pandemic had
been met for what became known as the
2009 swine flu pandemic
a third important point
is that the inquiry needs to be aware of
the difference between structure central
government departments Regional
government divorce administrations and
the like
policy which is government departments
and bodies setting out rules as to how
they'll go about deciding what to do the
planning what is everyone meant to do
and finally operational response how
services and help are actually provided
they are all important but operational
response is not a matter for module one
equally
issues such as the core political and
administrative decision making the
merits and the timings of national
lockdowns vaccines the specifics of
healthcare the response of the Care
sector the detail of test and Trace PPE
procurement financial assistance
the government's response and the
impacts the pandemic on various sectors
of the country
particularly including the vulnerable
offer later modules
the more detailed exploration of the way
in which the country responded has to
await those later modules
may I now then turn to the system for
preparedness
it is obvious my lady that the degree to
which covid-19 could be prevented from
laying waste to society was a matter
within the control of government and the
systems for eprr which existed
those systems may not be able to stop a
pandemic in its tracks but they ought to
be able to put in place measures and
understanding of virus understanding and
forecasting how it might develop
tracking it limiting transmission and
coping with the consequences of
large-scale transmission
in order to see what worked well and
what faltered or failed
I'm afraid it's necessary to have a
basic level of understanding of how the
systems were set up
many following this opening statement
may have some appreciation of the terms
and of the bodies of the structures
but but for those who do not it's
necessary to set out some short
definitions and explanations which will
assist in their understanding of the
evidence which you will shortly hear
it is a particularly complicated system
to help us guide listeners through it
could we have please on the screen
a document prepared by the inquiry
inq204014
my lady this is a document which the
inquiry team have prepared
um which sets out the basic structures
concerning eprr for the United Kingdom
and England and also for Scotland Wells
and Northern Ireland
the inq number is just a reference to
the inquiries electronic document system
I should say that this is a document
which is evolving
um we'll we will improve it as we go
along in the light of helpful comments
from core participants and that the
various governments and
default administrations the United
Kingdom could we go forward please to
page four
that Milady is a schematic
representation of the United Kingdom and
England's
emergency preparedness
response and resilience system
starting from the top
cabinet office
of whom of course we've heard much in
recent days is the government Department
in the United Kingdom responsible for
supporting the Prime Minister and the
cabinet
it is composed of various units that
support cabinet committees and which
coordinate the delivery of government
objectives but primarily working with
other government departments
one of its most important functions is
National Security and the coordination
of the United Kingdom government's
response to crises
my lady it's obvious that in an
emergency the cabinet office needs to
draw on the expertise of other
government departments in its emergency
planning
and so there is something called the
lead government Department
in relation to a pandemic it's obvious
that the lead government department will
be the Department of Health and Social
Security and we can see in the middle of
the screen and I emphasize
just for convenience sake we're focusing
on the United Kingdom and England in
this schematic design
rather than looking at Scotland Wells
and Northern Ireland for which there are
equally schematic designs of no less
importance
so the blue part in the middle of the
picture represents the department for
Health and Social care
lead government departments are the
government departments which are
appointed to deal and lead on issues
which concern and affect the most
so Milady one of the questions which
you'll be addressing is whether or not
this lead government Department model
the correct one for a whole system civil
emergency or do the requirements of this
acute type of Crisis require a different
approach if so what approach should that
be it is self-evident that in a crisis
of the magnitude of the covid-19
pandemic the burden could not solely be
carried by the lead government
Department because of course the
pandemic affected every part of the
government and of British public life
from education to the care sector of
course to the treasury to our finances
our jobs and and livelihood
the department for Health and Social
care oversees the National Health
Service in England it oversees the
United Kingdom's arm-length bodies such
as the United Kingdom Health Security
Agency
so a primary question going into the
pandemic was was the Department of
Health and Social Security adequately
prepared
did it identify with sufficient adequacy
The Surge capacity in terms of Hospital
infrastructure clinicians and support
workers that would be required
during the module one time frame
the Civil contingency Secretariat was
the cabin office unit that managed both
United Kingdom government's preparedness
for and its response to Major Nationwide
emergencies
my lady it was established in 2001 and
in July 2022 after the pandemic was
split into two separate functions
focusing on its emergency response
functions the Cobra unit by which we'll
hear a great deal more and resilience
Frameworks called the resilience
directorate and thank you very much the
Civil contingency secretary has been
highlighted at the top of the screen
towards the top right of the screen you
will see a reference to the National
Security risk assessment
the National Security risk assessment is
the United Kingdom government's
classified assessment of the top
National level risks facing the United
Kingdom
the assessment focuses on both the
likelihood of the risk occurring and the
impact it would have were it to happen
and it has a public-facing document the
national risk register
which provides information for those who
have formal contingency planning
responsibilities at a national regional
and local level
we know of course what the broad nature
of future emergencies might be
natural hazards include Global health
challenges animal and plant diseases
growing antimicrobial resistance space
weather events extreme weather climate
change
infrastructure collapse or perhaps the
unintended consequence of
human endeavor and artificial
intelligence
the world is an uncertain place and
risks seem set only to grow
through the exact nature of those major
risks cannot of course be identified in
advance
and because it's not possible to know in
advance with certainty which risks will
crystallize
and how and because it's not practical
to plan for every major risk there will
always be uncertainty
so the government
draws up policies
and those policies are by their nature
of more General application
but both the policies and the Planned
operational responses must build in the
ability to respond to the unknown and
provide for contingencies
government planning must be flexible
were the governments of the four
countries flexible enough with their
policy making
was the consideration of what those
risks might be and how they could be
prepared for sufficiently imaginative
my lady you will hear evidence
that for many years an influenza
pandemic was assessed as being one of
the most likely risks to the United
Kingdom
but what about other risks that whilst
they might be less likely could be just
as if not more deadly
did planning sufficiently address the
risk not only of the known
but the unknown
a new pathogen a new disease a disease X
as it's known with pandemic potential
did planners pay sufficient focus on
potential impact as opposed to
likelihood
with covid the evidence will demonstrate
that the government thought that the
greater risk was an influenza pandemic
and therefore devoted more time and
resources to that possibility
in the event we were hit of course by a
Coronavirus
that might suggest a lack of flexibility
or proper foresight
or perhaps the policies plans and
structures were so flexible and Broad so
as to cover any reasonable possibility
that this prevented us from focusing
enough upon those particular risks which
as I say
whilst being perhaps less likely could
cause us more harm
so a core question in module one will be
to what extent was thought given to and
planning devoted to the risk of a new
emerging infectious disease that was not
influenza
did the system of planning become
self-validating or complacent
so that that question was not asked or
if it was asked by individuals was not
listened to
what extent were the likely consequences
of either influenza or a new and
emerging infectious disease reassessed
my lady the evidence may show
that there was a degree of assumption in
the process
that if there was to be an influenza
pandemic it would be bound to lead to
hundreds of thousands of deaths
this was because planners positively
planned on what was known as the
reasonable worst case scenario the W the
rwcs
planning for the worst case that could
realistically happen
sense of planning for the worst case
that could realistically happen is
obvious you need to prepare everyone to
respond to that possibility to have
enough resources enough surge capacity
enough room for maneuver in the health
care and social care assistance enough
PPE and so on
but not at the expense of pausing and
asking
what more can we do to ensure we don't
get to that stage at all
the evidence may show simply and
terribly that not enough people thought
to ask because everybody started to
assume it would be flu
and if it was flu
diagnostic testing case detection and
isolation are less effective on account
of the shorter incubation period
and as I've said there would always be
antiviral medicine and vaccines and a
national pandemic flu service
so my lady to what extent did United
Kingdom government and the devault
administrations have a strategy
for preventing a pandemic from having
disastrous effects
as opposed to dealing with the
disastrous effects of the pandemic and
the reasonable worst case scenario which
was assumed
to follow
Keith I've been encouraged to take
regular breaks as you know for the
purposes of sonographer and others would
that be a convenient it's a very
convenient moment thank you I should be
back at 11 30.
yes Mr cage
my lady I was addressing you in relation
to whether or not the United Kingdom
government and the divorce
Administrations
had a strategy at all for preventing
a pandemic from having disastrous
effects
as opposed to dealing with the
disastrous effects of the pandemic
part of the answer May lie in the
doctrinal thinking that underpins
the emergency preparedness response and
resilience system
so the United Kingdom government and the
default administrations adopted what is
known as the integrated emergency
management structure
and it had six phases
anticipate assess
prevent prepare respond and recover
and this concept underpinned
both the approach to emergency
preparedness response from resilience
and the revised law and legal
Arrangements which were introduced into
this area in the early 2000s
so one of the issues for you in this
module will be whether or not this was
the right approach for the United
Kingdom and the devault Administrations
did this approach under the integrated
management emergency management
structure have the right emphasis
were these stages the right ones so for
example although I've made a reference
to prevent and prepare
did this doctrinal approach
sufficiently ensure that the government
thought about how to stop the terrible
consequences that it was planning for
appearing in the first place
furthermore
doctrinally
was there sufficient independent and
rigorous expert advice was that expert
advice in the government system
sufficient in its range and diversity
did the government learn sufficiently
from the experiences of other countries
especially those such as Taiwan South
Korea and Singapore who'd learned from
the SARS one and the MERS epidemics to
which I made reference earlier Andrew's
preparations were in fact more advanced
in some ways than our own
ordinary though it may seem
given that it's a word that will be
forever seared into the national
consciousness
little debate pre-pandemic of whether a
lockdown might prove to be necessary in
the event of a runaway virus let alone
how a lockdown could be avoided
very little thought was given to Howe if
it proved to be necessary something as
complex and difficult and damaging as a
national lockdown could be put in place
at all
equally there appears to be a failure to
Think Through the potentially massive
impact on education and the economy of
trying to control a runaway virus in
this way
was there an element of complacency
based on our recent experiences
including the ranking in the global
Health security index our response to
swine flu in 2009 and the United
Kingdom's undoubted successes in
ensuring that SARS and MERS did not
spread
did our experience of the 2009 swine flu
lead to concerns about overreacting
my lady there had been numerous
exercises
but to what extent were those exercises
adequate in terms of scope and frequency
and the persons who were invited to
participate in them and what was learned
from those exercises
what lessons were taken away from them
in relation to Future risks and future
preparedness
at a more fundamental level therefore
should there be an eprr agency an
independent agency to take complete
control of national planning
preparedness and resilience
such an agency might be responsible for
managing the structure with the
assistance of the rest of government
checking it and testing it it could
provide advice to the government and the
devault administration's a long-term
strategy it could commission external
expertise from the fields of Technology
Health economics and the military
perhaps there should be a central
leadership position accountable to
Parliament with responsibility for whole
system preparedness resilience and
response
Milady I mentioned a few moments ago the
legal structures which were introduced
in the 2000s one of the the most
important legal reforms based around
this doctrinal approach to which I've
made reference was the introduction of
the Civil contingencies act in 2004
it provided the framework for civil
protection in the United Kingdom and it
identifies and establishes a set of
roles and responsibilities for those
involved in eprr at a local level and
allows for the making of emergency
regulations to help deal with the most
serious of emergencies
and if we could have please the document
the chart up
inq204104 please at page four
thank you
you will see in the bottom left hand
corner of this chart which is again is
the United Kingdom and England won
around about August 2019 a reference in
the very bottom left-hand Corner two
local category one responders and local
Category 2 responders
so part one of the Civil contingencies
act 2004 provided for two groups of
responders to an emergency category 1
responders
namely the police and the Emergency
Services local authorities and and the
Health Care System the NHS and Category
2 responders utility and transport
providers water companies health and
safety executive and communication
providers
now those category one responders are
subject to the full set of civil
protection duties they're required to
assess the risk of emergencies occurring
and users to inform contingency planning
locally they put in place the actual
emergency plans upon which Reliance is
based in the event of a crisis they put
in place business continuity management
Arrangements they make information
available to the public and they share
information with other local responders
to enhanced coordination
the category
degree organizations by contrast the
cooperating bodies are less likely to be
involved in planning work but they'll be
heavily involved in incidents that
affect their own sector
they have a lesser set of Duties they're
obliged to cooperate and share
information but they don't and they're
not obliged to react in the same way as
the category 1 organizations
but there are no comparable legal duties
on central government
the only legal Duties are on those
category 1 and Category 2 responders
so in the event of a national crisis
which engages engages the whole of
government
is there a case for the imposition of
legal duties on central government as
well
across England
local resilience forums support the
planning between all those various
bodies they consist of the category 1
and Category 2 responders and they are
the bodies which plan which prepare for
the crises or emergencies which might
befall the locality and if we look again
at the bottom of the page in the bottom
left-hand Corner we can see local
resilience forums the bodies into which
the local category one responders and
Category 2 responders report
my lady
there may be some degree of surprise
that in this important system of
emergency response and preparation
the bodies who are primarily concerned
with planning for emergencies and indeed
responding to emergencies are appear to
be right down at the bottom left-hand
side of the page and and to be local
and the reason for that is is that the
the United Kingdom system works on the
basis of subsidiarity
that principle is designed to ensure
that those with local knowledge make the
decisions on the ground they are the
people who will know the area well and
therefore can best respond to
flooding or some crisis or emergency
which uh envelops a a town or a part of
a town or part of the countryside uh or
the region
but those local resilience forums are if
you like at one end therefore of these
lines of communication is that the best
model
our local resilience forums and their
devolved equivalents adequately
resourced accountable and led
to what extent did the central
government when we were hit by the
pandemic deal with the local resilience
forums ensure that they had what they
needed to be able to respond
and in this system that there is a
further conundrum which is that local
resilience forums deal with planning but
response when an emergency strikes is
actually in the hands of a different
group called the Strategic coordination
groups
think we should have that in yellow just
above local resilience forums if that
could be highlighted
we can see strategic coordination groups
these are different bodies but largely
composed of the same bodies that make up
the lrf the local resilience forum and
they focus on the actual response to an
emergency is there an unnecessary degree
of duplication here
another important area concerns the
resilience emergencies division halfway
up the page on the left
that is the division which rests within
the ministry of housing communities and
local government now in fact the
department for leveling up housing and
communities
and it provides advice to the local
resilience forums through its resilience
advisors which we can see a little bit
further down the left-hand side of the
page
so in it's in essence the resilience
emergencies division is liaison with the
national and local tiers of response
so we have already therefore an
understanding that in this system you
have the cabinet office you have the
lead government Department you have
other government departments and you
have the resilience emergency division
of the Department of leveling up housing
in communities all concerned with
ensuring that the system works
is that really the best way of doing it
no less important as I've earlier said
are the devolved Administrations
preparedness and resilience are devolved
matters meaning that they're the
responsibility of each divulge
Administration and not of Westminster
and this inquiry is looking of course at
the states of preparedness resilience in
all the countries
but on the subject of devolution
an important issue therefore immediately
arises
has the Devolution settlement
which has made preparedness and
resilience at evolved matter
struck the correct balance between the
leadership which is obviously necessary
in any whole country civil emergency
whole nation whole United Kingdom
emergency and the benefits of a tailored
localized response
so if we could please then look briefly
at page six in this inq document
and then go forward yes thank you we
will see at the top of the page pandemic
preparedness and response structures
Scotland 2009
and because as I've said resilience and
preparedness of devolved issues if we
could
please Zoom back out thank you and see
the whole page you'll see of course that
the vast majority of the bodies in
Scotland dealing with preparedness and
resilience are our Scottish bodies but
the linked United Kingdom comes from the
cabinet office which sits on top of the
whole structure which is why the cabin
office is at the top of the chart
and linked through Cobra the Civil
contingency secretary which I made
reference the scientific Advisory Group
for emergencies down to the devault
administration level
page 10 please
[Music]
the analogous scheme for Wales
broadly speaking in 2019
again you can see that all the bodies in
the
the bottom two-thirds of the page
are
devolved bodies
and again the link to United Kingdom
comes through the cabinet office at the
top
and page 14
similarly in relation to Northern
Ireland
so my lady you will see from those pages
and and those schemes that there are a
number of important bodies in Scotland
Wells and Northern Ireland which carry
out analogous functions to to those in
in Westminster and England
in Scotland I went to YouTube them the
Scottish resilient resilience
partnership
there are Regional resilience
Partnerships in Scotland each Regional
resilience partnership has its own local
resilience partnership
there are then a number of ministerial
bodies for government resilience that
are government resilience officials and
emergency Arrangements were arranged
through the Scottish government
resilience room in Wales we have the
Wales resilience Forum The Joint
Emergency Services Group local
resilience forums and in Northern
Ireland the Civil contingencies group
emergency response groups and strategic
coordination groups
my lady there are a profusion of bodies
in relation to Northern Ireland a vital
issue is the impact in January or what
was the impact of in January 2020 on
preparedness response and resilience
Arrangements of the prior collapse in
power sharing
is well known the Good Friday agreement
or Belfast agreement which was signed in
April 1998 provided for a new devault
system of government with an assembly
and executive installment
however thereafter power sharing as you
know was suspended on a number of times
most relevantly it was suspended between
January 2017 when the then Shin feigned
Deputy first Minister the late Martin
McGinnis resigned and remained suspended
until Saturday the 11th of January 2020
just as the pandemic was starting to
spread to the province
during that time Northern Ireland was
managed by civil servants without
ministerial oversight
we will therefore be exploring to what
extent that lack of ministerial input
affected the civil emergency
arrangements and in particular the
inability because of the collapse of the
power sharing agreement to make any
significant improvements to this
structure during that interregnum
those with sharp eyes will see that each
of the four nations has its own Public
Health body Public Health Wales this is
a public health agency in Northern
Ireland and public health Scotland in
England the health Protection Agency was
established in 2003 in April
2013 Public Health England was
established incorporating the health
Protection Agency
alongside Public Health functions
previously carried out by the Department
of Health and Regional Health
authorities
thereafter
and it's not on the scheme because the
scheme represents the position in 2020
or 2019 rather in April 2021 the UK
Health security Authority was
established which took on parts of
Public Health England focusing on health
protection alongside the functions of
NHS test and Trace and The Joint
biosecurity Center
but the public health England's Health
Improvement functions were transferred
to the Department of Health and Social
care
my lady another issue therefore for a
module one why did those structural
changes occur why did they occur when
they did were they an improvement
particularly the abolition of Public
Health England and the bifurcation of
Public Health protection from public
health Improvement
what was the state of pandemic Readiness
and preparedness for each of those
bodies
there had also been significant reforms
to the national and local systems for
public health the Health and Social Care
Act 2012 transferred most public health
functions from NHS bodies in England and
Wales to local authorities
at the same time local authorities with
public health responsibilities were
required to employ a specialist director
of Public Health
were directors of Public Health utilized
effectively within their local
authorities did those Public Health
reforms make our Public Health
structures more or less resilient and
able to respond to a pandemic
my lady all these bodies and entities
have to be run managed and paid for they
have to be supervised and told what to
do drafting has to be done of a myriad
number of policy documents and guidance
they have to be assured which is just
another word for being tested or checked
Who provided oversight as to that state
of preparedness of local responders arms
length bodies lead government
departments other government departments
and all those processes had to be
provided for discussed agreed and put
into place
we've seen my lady in the written
evidence that relevant bodies committees
and subcommittees within government were
renamed or sometimes disbanded
altogether only for other strikingly
similar ones to be set up in the
immediate aftermath
one might conclude looking at the
schematic schedules that there was a
labyrinthine and confusing picture
was it really necessary
were there proper links
between central government and local
Authority not just tick box consultation
whether proper Communications between
central government and the devault
administrations that were not just
dependent on the political will of
ministers
so my lady standing back
was this civil emergency system as good
as it could be
were these structures adequate
or was their proliferation a hindrance
to the United Kingdom's response
what can you do
to make this better
turning finally to the end product of
all this how to put actual plans in
place
so that everybody knows actually what to
do in the event of an emergency
how were those plans drawn up checked
and compared
was there adequate testing of plans for
an actual pandemic
were the structures in place for
ensuring the plans for the necessary
surge in healthcare and social care
provision were there for stockpilene
distribution of PPE and mass diagnostic
diagnostic testing
and of course
those areas are only concerned with the
health consequences of a pandemic
but a pandemic is prone to effect as
I've said every area of public life
and so where were the plans and how
adequate were they
for the shielding employment support
disruption to schools border policy
lockdowns
and as I've said the profoundly unequal
impact of a pandemic on the vulnerable
and marginalized
lastly
the pandemic struck the United Kingdom
just as it was leaving the European
Union
that departure required an enormous
amount of planning and preparation
particularly to address what were likely
to be the severe consequences of a No
Deal exit on food and Medicine supplies
Travel and Transport business borders
and so on
it is clear that such planning from 2018
onwards crowded out and prevented some
or perhaps a majority of the
improvements That central government
itself understood were required to be
made to resilience planning and
preparedness
did the attention therefore page the
risks of a No Deal exit operation
yellowhammer as it was known
drain the resources in capacity that
should have been continuing the fight
against the next pandemic
that should have been utilized in
preparing the United Kingdom for civil
emergency
or did all that generic and operational
planning
in fact lead to people being better
trained and well marshaled
I didn't fight much prepared to deal
with covid and also to the existence of
improved trade medicine and Supply links
my lady on the evidence so far but it
will be a matter for you
we very much fear that it was the former
one of the most important features of
module one will be to consider whether
Health inequalities were appropriately
considered in the planning for a
pandemic and I leave this issue to last
in reflection of the fact that it is an
issue which will find Its Reflection
through the entirety of the evidence
which you have directed be called in
module one
the inquiry will look at how the lives
of different types of people with
different experiences were regarded by
those with the duty of protecting them
for each of the decision makers the
civil servants and those tasked with the
responsibility of preparing our systems
were social and clinical vulnerabilities
considered by them
at all
when the emergency plans were drawn up
did they have regard to the social
inequalities and health inequalities
which would undoubtedly be exacerbated
by the outcome of that planning
the evidence will reveal the iranity to
that question
so my lady there is a great deal to
cover
I think I've said quite enough you will
hear now opening statements from Council
representing the module one core
participants and then we will turn to
the evidence of the witnesses whom Kate
Blackwell King's Council and I will then
examine
thank you very much indeed Mr Keith Mr
Weatherby
others do the turning on of the
microphone Irene okay sorry to interview
I still got red haven't you
yeah
good good morning Milady just
um I'll be about 30 minutes
um I hope no more
um
on the 8th of June of 2015 then Prime
Minister David Cameron gave a speech to
the G7 in Bavaria
a United Kingdom government press
release ahead of the speech said this
and I quote
and a stark warning to other G7 leaders
the PM will say that the world must be
far better prepared for future health
pandemics that could be more aggressive
and harder to contain than the recent
Ebola outbreak
experts have warned that lessons must be
learned from what happened a more
virulent disease in future transmitted
by coughing like flu or measles for
example would have a much more
devastating impact if a better approach
is not put in place unquote
that was 2015.
The Who indicate that globally there
have been almost seven million
verifiable deaths from covid in a recent
article in The Economist Dr Tedros Adnan
gabriellesis director general of the who
said the real number is likely to be
around 20 million
less than five years after Mr Cameron's
speech a virulent disease transmitted by
respiratory means had arrived and caused
Devastation around the world
the Brie families would like to know
have the better approach that Mr Cameron
spoke about being put into place in the
United Kingdom what did his government
or those after him do about the threat
he had so powerfully raised with world
leaders
whatever the answer to that question for
well over a decade prior to the arrival
of covid the United Kingdom National
risk assessments as we've just heard had
recognized that the threat of a pandemic
was high and that the threat was not
only flu but also a quite separate type
of new and emerging disease unknown
it cannot be said therefore that this
terrible disease this pandemic was a
Black Swan event an event so unlikely
that it was practically unforeseeable
nor did its emergence rely upon the
coming together of a number of unlikely
phenomena in a so-called Perfect Storm
the inquiry experts
Bruce Mann and Professor Alexander later
this week we anticipate from their
report will conclude that whole system
preparedness for a novel disease
pandemic in the UK was quote wholly
inadequate as of January 2020. how was
that allowed to happen how did that come
to pass
what we anticipate will be said
was that those same National risk
assessments recognize that the impact of
flu was assessed as high with what is
termed as the reasonable worst case
scenario of up to 750 000 deaths but the
reasonable worst case scenario for the
unknown new disease was put at a Far Low
lower figure between 100 and perhaps 2
000 deaths no doubt justifications will
be given
however taken taking Mr Cameron's
warning that the next emerging disease
might have the characteristics of Ebola
seventy percent for Fatality and the
transmissibility of measles ninety
percent of those without immunity it's
hard to Fathom why the UK government's
National risk assessment talk search a
complacent view of its likely impact and
did so repeatedly
for the families therefore module one
should address the key question of
whether the United Kingdom did
everything reasonably practicable to
prevent a foreseeable pandemic of this
type or mitigate its impact if it
arrived
why was there apparently no overall plan
no whole system plan
was there a minister with overall
responsibility a clear and effective
framework to ensure everyone worked
together ensure everyone was properly
resourced and trained and had the right
equipment ensured the planners had the
right scientific and expert advice and
formulated appropriate contingency plans
with their proper insufficient auditing
and Assurance mechanisms in place to
ensure the highest quality preparedness
possible
it appears none of this
Mr Keith's very helpful document put up
on Street screen might of itself answer
whether there was a clear and effective
framework
as we understand the evidence it appears
that the closest to an overall plan was
the Department of Health 2011 pandemic
flu preparedness plan
was that fit for purpose for a non-flue
pandemic in 2020
why wasn't there this whole system plan
many civil emergencies are local as Mr
Keith touched on and require a local
response backed up by central government
support only where necessary
the Manchester Arena bombing outrage or
flooding perhaps
but wasn't it obvious that other civil
emergencies including pandemics or by
their very nature National whole system
emergencies and require National whole
system planning as a result
why was there apparently such Reliance
on 2011 department of health planning
wasn't it obvious that pandemic planning
had to go far beyond public health and
Healthcare
options for Border controls and
screening travel restrictions and
quarantine maintaining Food Supplies and
public security enforcing emergency
restrictions on movement and assembly
maintaining education and Social Service
systems and protecting the economic
well-being of the country and jobs
for all matters Way Beyond the remed of
the Department of Health and Social care
the 2021 National Audit office report on
preparedness for covid noted that the
cabinet office through its civil
contingency Secretariat coordinated
government planning and response
it found no evidence that there was a
consensus on the so-called risk appetite
of the government across departments
which means the level of impact the
government would deem an acceptable
outcome from the particular risk
indeed the same report notes that the
cabinet office told the National Audit
office that the government's risk
appetite had changed as the pandemic
arrived on our Shores meaning that it
lowered the threshold for the health and
societal impact of the pandemic that it
deemed acceptable
how the families ask was there
coordination of relevant government
departments if they were working to
different agendas why the families ask
would planning be done on one basis and
then response on another
in fact the same report
indicated that a cross-government
working group review in February and
March 2020 rated more than 80 percent of
the plans as being unable to meet the
demands of any actual incident
and it also noted that the cabinet
office did not have the remit to carry
out oversight or Assurance over lead or
other government departments so no
central government responsibilities
a coordinating Secretariat within the
cabinet office would actually had no
oversight or Assurance remit or powers
and different government departments
working to different agendas and
acceptable outcomes
the inquiry will have to determine
whether that was a sensible approach to
planning and preparedness for a National
Emergency or a recipe for chaos and
failure
did planning sufficiently concentrate on
the human impact and not process and did
it fatalistically Con concentrate on
dealing with the aftermath of the
so-called reasonable worst case
scenarios rather than prevention and
mitigation
first and foremost planning should
concentrate on prevention and mitigation
not how to deal with the number of
bodies
it is important that no one forgets
amongst all the figures and statistics
and percentages though the true cost of
the pandemic should be measured in the
last year's love happiness potential and
missed Milestones of every person who
did not survive to see the world return
to some version of normal
it's measured in the enduring grief of
those we represent For Whom the world
will never return to normal
because they lost a crucial part of that
world it will be measured for years to
come by those still suffering the
effects of long covert
the Kobe Brie families for justice
represents a large and diverse group of
bereaved individuals from across the
United Kingdom
they come from all walks of life many by
Dent of their occupations as well as
personal circumstances saw and felt this
pandemic on many levels
many identify structural discrimination
and unaddressed health inequalities as
contributing to their loss
the families have different areas of
Interest different experiences different
questions that they United not only by
grief but by their determination that
the legacy of this inquiry an inquiry
for which they campaigned is one of
Justice accountability and most
importantly change
they want to save lives
Joe Goodman believes her family her
father contracted covid whilst attending
an outpatient appointment at his local
hospital and sadly died
he was clinically vulnerable he'd not
been given advice about the risks or
about shielding and there were no
apparent infection controls at the
hospital
Joe believes that if there had been
proper planning and preparedness and
Swift action to limit Community
infections to implement effective
hospital infection controls and to
protect the vulnerable then her father
might not have died
there are of course thousands of Joe
Goodmans
Joe met Matt Fowler whose father had
also died from covid on Facebook in
Spring of 2020
Matt's dad was a previously healthy man
in his 50s
Joe and Matt did not know each other
they lived and lived in different parts
of the country
together they formed a support group for
others like them and that subsequently
evolved into the CB ffj UK and the
campaign to get answers and to try to
achieve changes that meant that their
devastating losses would not happen to
someone else and they've been joined by
six and a half thousand others from all
corners of the United Kingdom amongst
them is Salia arson who throughout the
pandemic was a front-line doctor within
the emergency department at a hospital
in Wales
and then specifically for the second
wave within intensive care where she
treated critically ill covered patients
some of whom died
during this period in December 2020
sadly saleh's father our son UL haq
choudhary caught covered and died
Salia has produced and reported on a
very powerful channel for dispatches
documentary for which she filmed for
four months during the pandemic between
October 2020 and January 2021 within her
own Intensive Care Unit it's available
on Channel 4 and open source
before training to be a doctor Salia
served with the Royal Army Medical Corps
she contrasts the state of preparedness
in the British army which incorporate
incorporates robust regular training
they're putting on taking off from being
operational in protective suits
including respirators respirators
with the state of preparedness she
experi experienced in the NHS
where no such training in PPE took place
throughout two years at Medical School
enduring her subsequent 14 years as an a
e doctor
Salia is one of six siblings five
doctors and a pharmacist
they work in different parts of the UK
in all the individual years of practice
none of them has had any such training
in PPE
neither Salia or her siblings were ever
party to involved in or made aware of
any preparedness training or learning
from exercises such as cygnus Signet or
Alice
they have never been involved locally
regionally or nationally in any policy
clinical or management training
exercises relating to an outbreak of an
infectious disease
Salia asks why when the merits of
clinical practice in protective clothing
training exercising and awareness of
emergency plans for Frontline Medics and
essential service workers are all well
known and documented
a disproportionate number of the cbffj
families are sadly from black and brown
communities whose loved ones died often
as Frontline health or social Care staff
doctors cleaners carers others loved
ones were transport workers or worked in
the gig economy
they want to know if structural racism
or the disproportionate effects of a
pandemic on ethnic minority communities
was considered as a part of preparedness
and planning never mind the response to
the pandemic and if not why not
Jean adamson's father died in a care
home to which patients were transferred
from hospital without testing
Gene is a consultant who has worked in
the area of social care governance for
many years
and has been an advisor to the Care
Quality commission and has first-hand
knowledge of the lack of contingency
planning in the sector
amongst her questions or why were there
no or insufficient plans to prevent the
transmission of covid between homes due
to the use of agency workers and
transfers between homes and hospitals
without testing
where was the protective ring around
Care Homes as claimed by the former
Health secretary Matt Hancock
Kim Nutt the partner of an ambulance
care assistant wants to know why he was
not supplied with sufficient PPE or
proper guidance as to what protective
equipment he should wear
it's a necessity for proper guidance
stockpiles and surge supply of basic
equipment should have been obvious if
they had been proper preparedness
John Sullivan's daughter lived with a
serious disability
he witnessed the lack of any planning to
protect her as a disabled person
and to the country he is concerned that
a treatment triage tool may have taken
account of her disability in a
discriminatory way
he wants to know what planning and
preparedness there was to protect people
especially vulnerable through disability
in what regard if any there was for
combating the effects of structural
discrimination against disabled people
councilor Sarah butikofa was the leader
of a District Council in Norfolk
throughout the pandemic and as a
bereaved family member
she witnessed firsthand the lack of
resourcing and the complete lack of
guidance or clear policy from central
government relating to multiple issues
such as PPE supplies lockdowns
vulnerable adult care Arrangements Food
Supplies and multiple other non-fud
pharmaceutical interventions
she questions where was the central
responsibility for planning and
preparedness and why was there
insufficient resourcing
I could of course go on but I'm sure
everyone understands these are real and
raw issues for the families there are of
course many many others
Barbara from South Wales Martina from
Northern Ireland Ian from Scotland
that is why they've asked you to hear
some of their stories within the
hearings
to evidence and illustrate the apparent
lack of proper planning and preparedness
across many sectors
that's why so many of them have stood
outside this building today holding
photos of their lost loved ones to
highlight that their stories must not be
forgotten
essentially the inquiry has to address
three questions
what happened what went wrong and how do
we ensure that everything reasonably
possible is done to prevent it happening
again
three words facts accountability change
from that perspective the family
suggests that the fundamental topics
within the scopa module one are one
at a UK level who had responsibility for
civil emergency resilience preparedness
and planning
where did the book stop
two who was responsible for assessing
the risk of a pandemic such as covid and
its likely impact and how was it done
what was that assessment and was it as
accurate as it could have it should have
been on the available evidence
was the methodology and evidential basis
in the public domain
was it properly scrutinized and
challenged
three
why was there no whole system planned to
prevent such a pandemic or mitigate its
effects
who was responsible for such National
planning as there was
did it take proper and sufficient
account of all relevant scientific
advice and did it effectively integrate
the individual plans of lead government
departments and others
four was that planning and preparedness
optimal
was there sufficient understanding of it
amongst leading policy makers including
ministers
was pandemic planning effectively
communicated to Frontline essential
services in the General Public
was it sufficiently resourced was there
appropriate exercising and training was
there sufficient engagement with
communities and proper consideration of
issues of discrimination and
vulnerabilities
was it adversely affected by the
diversion of resources to deal with
brexit
was it affected by political
reservations about the who or other
International bodies including those in
the EU
five in terms of the Civil emergencies
framework were the responsibilities on
central government clear
indeed as we've heard were there any
such responsibilities on central
government or was the framework
strikingly deficient in that sense
was the integration of Central and local
emergency planning and auditing and
Assurance so as to ensure an optimal and
jointer response
what framework was there to ensure that
the UK government and each of the
devolved administrations integrated
their approaches
was there a persistent failure across
government to identify learn and improve
on responses to crises as referred to in
the 2022 internal government crisis
capabilities review
six to what extent were the citizens of
Northern Ireland disadvantaged by the
lack of statutory duties on the
equivalent of category 1 and 2
responders in Northern Ireland why did
that Gap exist at all
seven was there a culture of secrecy
surrounding civil emergency planning and
preparedness
did this include scientific advice in
particular from sage and publication of
results and Lessons Learned From a
number of pandemic exercises
in our written submissions we reference
a device given to Matt Hancock former
Health secretary the publication of
cygnus would lead to criticism of lack
of preparedness a reference which we say
is significant in illustrating this
issue
did a closed institutional culture
reduce the opportunity for challenge to
orthodoxies and did it reduce the
autonomy of scientists to frame their
own questions rather than be restricted
to answering the questions of others
did a closed culture promote or fail to
counteract structural discrimination
or to consider Health inequalities
and eight to what extended austerity
reduce the capacity for preparedness
where resources diverted from civil
emergency planning to maintain other
business as usual Frontline Services
because decision makers hoped
emergencies May well not happen on their
watch
was former Chancellor and architect of
austerity George Osborne correct when he
said that those financial policies fixed
the roof whilst the Sun was shining
or is Dr Jonathan flexman of doctors in
unite correct when he described non-nhs
Public Health funding reductions as
stripping the lead off the roof to make
the buckets to catch the rain
the families expect the evidence will
show a lack of responsibility in
government for civil emergency
preparedness with little or no
ministerial leadership and a chaos of
committees which led to poor planning
and ultimately a reactive rather than
proactive response to the virus
we anticipate the evidence will show
that the most fundamental consequence of
this was a slow reaction with a pandemic
time where was a slow reaction and with
a pandemic time is of the essence and
lost time is measured in Lost lives
I've already noted that there was a
national risk assessment which correctly
identified newly emerging diseases such
as covid as a threat to the UK but
significantly underestimated the likely
impact
if that is correct why
between the turn of the century and the
pandemic the two serious outbreaks of
coronavirus is SARS and MERS
had as we've heard far higher fatality
rates than covered
neither disease made a significant
impact in the UK most probably because
of their transmissibility or their
infection rate being low but also
because Swift and effective measures
were taken in other countries where they
arose
if this was the reason why National risk
assessment successively rated the
potential impact of pandemic flu as
extremely high but the potential impact
of an emerging disease is low
this was a case of Reliance on chance
outcomes in past outbreaks rather than a
properly informed view as to whether a
different chance would lead to a
catastrophic outcome the next time
according to the Nao report when asked
the cabinet office asserted that quote
diseases such as Ebola were expected to
burn themselves out quickly as had been
the case on previous occasions
learning lessons from the past is vital
fighting the last war rather than
planning for the next one is a
fundamental mistake
there is no scientific evidence of an
inverse relationship between virulence
and transmissibility David Cameron seems
to understood that in 2015 and indeed
it's a fact expressly stated in the 2011
pandemic flu plan itself
why then did ministers including Mr
Cameron and scientific advisors not
challenge the narrative in successive
National risk assessments that an
unknown emerging disease would likely be
of relatively low impact and cause a low
number of fatalities
that's an important question with which
the inquiry will have to Grapple
if there had been actual ministerial
responsibility for civil emergency
preparedness and if there was actual
central government departmental
responsibility rather than this
apparently ad hoc coordination role
within the cabinet office might there be
in Greater Challenge and scrutiny
responsibility leads to accountability
leads to better decision making
knowledge that the buck lands at The
Minister's door concentrates Minds
if the scientific advice had been more
transparent
and scientists were able to determine
their own questions and encouraged to
challenge orthodoxies scientific
autonomy with the tendency to group
think and perhaps complacency have been
combated
in summary was the process for risk and
impact assessment robust was it
transparent and open to peer challenge
or challenged by policy makers
or were the assessments opaque
going forward should there be a
presumption that both the methodology
and the evidence for the risk and impact
assessments of each known threat should
be in the public domain except where
there is the clearest of National
Security issues
such an approach would Foster informed
discussion raise evidence beyond that
which has been considered behind closed
doors and lead to Greater public
understanding and engagement and
preparedness and planning and perhaps a
greater appetite for proper funding
the inquiry will have to consider
whether the labyrinthine risk and impact
assessment processes were a sensible
tapestry and finely tuned operation
or whether in reality it was a
hodgepodge Arrangement more colander
than coherent framework
the Stark facts not hindsight show that
in the years before covid there was no
room for complacency
going forward those realities mean there
is an urgent need to analyze the past
and optimize prevention and mitigation
for the future
the UK is of course amongst the richest
Nations on Earth it has mature
institutions including with respect to
health care and public health together
with Ireland it's an archipelago Islands
giving it obvious geographical
advantages
the UK was well placed to see a pandemic
coming and have effective defenses and
mitigations planning resilience and
preparedness it was well placed to see
the necessity to have options such as
border controls and screening of
entrance it was well placed to have
learned the importance and methodologies
of test and Trace used so effectively by
other nations in particular in Southeast
Asia and for other non-pharmaceutical
interventions including masks
restrictions on mass assemblies travel
lockdowns
all to be used intelligently and
proactively which crucially in this
context means early
it was a lack of incorporation of these
measures into planning and preparedness
responsible for them being deployed
later than was necessary
the families have no doubt this is the
case
the UK was well placed to have good
plans for PPE stockpiling and surge
manufacturing and supply of the same and
other things such as oxygen and medical
equipment
why was the availability of PPE in
particular so deficient
if we're right that the use of these
measures should have been learned from
recent coronavirus history and indeed
recent history of flu Ebola and other
diseases were there actually any UK
plans for each of them was there
resourcing
if so were the plans and resourcing
adequate or was the UK always one step
behind
prevaricating dithering delaying and
hoping for the best reacting rather than
acting proactively to save lives
minimize disruption and protect
communities and the economy
as has been outlined as far as we
understand the position the Civil
contingency Secretariat within the
cabinet office liaised with the lead
government departments who owned each
risk identified on the risk assessment
because the particular risk fell within
their area of responsibility
those lead government departments were
expected to have plans for those risks
we do not doubt that it was sensible for
the Department of Health to have had a
plan for a pandemic for obvious reasons
for the equally obvious reasons that
plan should have been integrated into
our whole system plan or at least fully
coordinated with the plans of multiple
other relevant departments and agencies
there was no framework requiring that to
happen and it was beyond the
responsibility of the cabinet office
whose remit was coordination and liaison
to the families that seems to have been
a fundamental failure
there are commonalities to civil
emergencies as well as differences
if a minister and Department had
responsibility for civil emergency
preparedness and planning or even a
statutory agency then it would be
responsible for whole system plans for
each identified threat incorporating the
planning not only of the lead department
but all the others
there are similarities with Jessup here
the joint Emergency Services
interoperability principles
the whole system response can work only
if each relevant Department each
responder each agency knows not only its
own role but also that of others
interoperability fails without Clarity
joint plans adequate resourcing training
and exercising
at the local tier level interoperability
between agencies occurs through the
local resilience forums that Mr Keith
touched upon
joint plans training and exercising why
is there no such framework for central
government or between central government
and the local tier
will learn no doubt that their efforts
to coordinate across government through
a myriad of committees
no doubt we'll be told that there was
learning and changes made beyond the
2011 pandemic flu plan
but we urge the inquiry to drill down
into what those produced in reality
we do understand
from the evidence that there was a
realization that the 2011 planning
strategy needed updating and a pandemic
flew preparedness board was established
but its work was stalled because of the
preoccupation with Readiness for brexit
and it appears few real changes were
made
is the reality that by January 2020
despite this realization that there was
a need for change there was an absence
of action an absence of planning which
would have allowed the UK to react
swiftly
leaving government to largely make up
the plan as it went along once covid
arrived
finally what might such a whole system
plan have looked like taking the 2011
plan as a starting point given the
experience of MERS and Ebola and a
number of exercises that had taken place
since we might have expected a plan
which said more than the bare assertion
in the 2011 plan that it could be
adapted for non-flue outbreaks
some aspects of a modern pandemic plan
perhaps right themselves early genomic
sequencing to enable development of
tests and establishing immediate vaccine
and antiviral research and development
and ensuring manufacturing and
laboratory capacity for both testing and
vaccines once available would be most
obvious
some of these aspects may have been
progressed well in this pandemic
although it's less than clear that this
was due to government or indeed planning
and we anticipate that there are aspects
of testing rollout and capacity which
was seriously inadequate
but a whole system plan should also
recognize that a newly emerging disease
might have different modes of
transmission it might have different
longevity of contagion and it might be
transmissible asymptomatically
the plan would therefore require a range
or menu of options has proved effective
particularly in Southeast Asia long
before 2020.
in some respects the plan would plainly
need to be multi-departmental or
multi-agency
screening at airports would need
interoperability with airport
authorities and the Border Force as well
as public health facilities restrictions
on assembly would need legal changes and
policing shielding the vulnerable
combating disproportionate effects due
to discrimination and protecting
education Social Services provision will
necessarily involve interoperability a
whole system plan would also include PPE
procurement and stockpiling and search
supply of equipment and oxygen antiviral
and vaccine development it would include
economic resilience and securing jobs
which required treasury planning and
plans for securing food and energy
supplies and distribution
with the lead government Department
system which fragmented preparedness to
narrow responsibilities there was little
chance of a rapid joined up effective
response with an array of tools
ready-made at its disposal
in conclusion
you will be told by some politicians
that austerity put the UK in a good
place to respond to the pandemic
but experts will point to its effect on
public health and local Authority
resilience funding
the inquiry will learn also of what
happened to health inequalities
concurrently with these cuts and reasons
why the widening of such inequalities
might have occurred as a result
we anticipate some senior civil servants
will defend the Civil contingencies
framework and argue that in fact it
worked well but you'll also hear the
view of the experts including Bruce Mann
one of the architects of the current
system who will say not only that UK
preparedness was wholly inadequate but
that they should going forward be clear
responsibilities on central government
to clear national standards and
competencies mechanisms of assurance and
adequate funding
indeed at the time the Civil
contingencies Act was enacted in 2004
there were recommendations that it
should contain central government
responsibilities as well as subsidiarity
to local responders that Mr Keith has
explained earlier we would argue an
opportunity lost at that time
the lack of central responsibilities
meant there was no single point of
responsibility and no mechanism for
collaboration cross-department or with
other agencies it meant there was little
or no Assurance or standard setting for
local responders in local resilience
forums and there was no framework for
collaboration and coordination with the
devolved authorities and Administrations
we anticipate Bruce Mann and Professor
Alexander will highlight the temptation
to pay lip service to responsibilities
which are not captured in law especially
when resources are tight
I've addressed at some length the closed
nature of the assessments and planning
in this area and it's and asserted that
it chilled public discourse and
challenge
but we also anticipate that the lack of
transparency and preparedness masked the
effects of austerity a loud structural
discrimination to continue unchecked and
led to learning from exercises or other
events
from translating into action
the answers to these questions and what
we do about them is vital
if the last three and a half years have
taught us anything
proper planning adequate resourcing and
Swift action saves lives
from the family's perspective it appears
that the UK had none of those three
things they want to know why and they
want it to change
I'm very grateful
Mr levery
good afternoon my lady
um
at this stage your leadership knows but
for anybody else watching that I
represent the Northern Ireland covid-19
bereaved families for justice
and in an approach to this which may
find some model in some part of the
findings of the inquiry in the future
we've adopted or joined up and coherent
approach
to making our oral and written
submissions so your leadership will see
that we have produced a joint document
and I command the submissions of Mr
Weatherby to the inquiry
and and to you melody
it is obvious
um I I then I represent the
Northern Ireland bereaved families
he lost loved ones young and old in a
variety of circumstances
including Care Homes hospitals and the
community
our families my lady have been impressed
by the robust approach
that you
and Mr Keith and his team are taking
you Milady have and your team have
worked incredibly hard to get this
inquiry started in despite prayer
support such a short period of time and
we have all the core participants have
been working hard and together with the
inquiry and with the inquiry team
and from what was said by Mr Keith
um already this morning we knew that he
has and you have already been listening
to the submissions that have been put in
right in so far and are
considering those very carefully
and our families have faith that this
inquiry will yield the results which
they search for
uh you know my lady that this inquiry
isn't simply about taking a robust
approach to individuals such as former
prime ministers
it's not that criticism it's not an
inquiry which will deal with personal
criticisms necessarily of those
individuals
but of course we know that new
individual is going to stand and no
government department is going to stand
in the way of progress of this inquiry
this inquiry as my clients know is about
the impact
and this module about the impact the
lack of preparedness had on them and on
society as a whole
and as I said we are here to support you
my lady in your task and finding out
in particular for our families from
Northern Ireland was Northern Ireland
prepared
what lessons for the future can be
learned
and should anyone or anybody
be made accountable
there are three areas I just want to
look at briefly in the the Civil
contingencies act which Mr Keith already
referred to
uh some science and some of the politics
involved
a a large part of the Civil
contingencies act uh 2004 did not
actually apply to Northland
and the problem was not just the
Devolution scheme but that in 2004
the executive and assembly were in
suspension
Northern Ireland was under tracked wheel
from Westminster
and the 2004 act did not confer duties
upon Westminster ministers
including those with direct drill powers
in Northern Ireland at the time
there is no equivalent devolved
legislation ever introduced despite this
being a key recommendation of the cygnus
report
and despite
the Northern Ireland Secretary of State
his expect the northern Secretary of
State's expectation in 2005 that
Northern Ireland would have quote a
similar level of protection for its
citizens as experienced elsewhere
the statutory obligations pertaining in
Northern Ireland
where
in contrast to the rest of the UK were
mere guidance Melody
the lack of cohesiveness was is planned
from the statement of Miss Allen from
the association of local authorities
Northern Ireland
it conveys a sense that in the absence
of statutory obligations and local
authorities there was relative inaction
with regard to planning and preparedness
was little if any formulation of
preparedness policies
and the
people in Northern Ireland therefore
were at a distinct disadvantage they had
less statutory protection compared to
other citizens in the UK
in terms of science Melody there was a a
disjuncture between central and devolve
government
and this is demonstrated in part by
Professor young who's a part-time
consultant and chief Scientific Advisor
but his request to join the chief
Scientific Advisor UK Network
and this was declined this requests was
declined only one representative for
each devolved Administration was allowed
there's no record of Northern Ireland
participation in sedge prior to the 29th
of March 2020
between 2009 to 2015 the senior medical
officer only had Observer status with no
speaking rights at the Joint Committee
on vaccination and immunization and the
advisory committee on dangerous
pathogens
Northern Ireland had no automatic
representation at Sage
and as
McBride put it policy makers in Northern
Ireland may have had more limited
awareness of the extent to which
uncertainty and the range of opinion is
expressed in scientific discussion
malaria Northern Ireland did not attend
Cobra meetings until the 2nd of March
the inquiry we say should consider the
recommendations
should consider recommendations that
ensure in future that Northern Ireland
Chief scientific advisors become part of
the UK Network on Sage and to ensure
Northern attendance at Cobra meetings
but Milady there was
a lack of knowledge
among political leaders
as well in relation to central
government planning and preparedness and
the reasons for it
the Michelle O'Neill the first Minister
designate
accepts a lack of knowledge of or at
least an ability to recall exercise
cygnus
despite it occurring while she was
ministered for health
Arlene Foster likewise despite being
first ministered during
operation cygnus
and the pandemic does not recall being
briefed quote as to the recommendations
made on foot of exercise sickness or any
steps the executive office intended to
take to improve pandemic preparedness
prior to the assembly collapsing in in
January 2017 in order to recall any
steps taken in relation to pandemic
preparedness between January 17 and
January 2020
we say the show's a low level of
interest in or the impact which cygnus
had on Northern Ireland decision making
the Michelle O'Neill's successor Robin
Swann who is the minister for health
during the pandemic does recall cygnus
and States his belief that the flu plan
provided a good foundation for Action
during the covid-19 pandemic
the inquiry Melody should of course
examine this assertion in light of its
exclusive focus on the influenza
pandemic
and in the event it's clear that
Northern Ireland devolve government
failed to implement a coherent response
to the pandemic and
humility May well find that it was
incapable of providing a coherent
response
there
is a common theme that runs throughout
common themes they're the lack of
statutory protection
lack of pandemic coordination and
general a lack of preparedness
for a pandemic
and the context of this is in is Decades
of political dysfunction in Northern
Ireland but malaria as Brenda Doherty
who you saw earlier on the film and who
made a statement and you will hear from
later on in this module
she put it in these terms that
and this is quoting from her statement
the vacuum in government was known not
only to our members but also to the
Westminster government
it's not prolonged lack of an executive
was having a detrimental impact on the
preparedness and resilience in respect
of emergencies in this jurisdiction the
UK government had a moral and
constitutional duty to act to ensure
that those living in this jurisdiction
would not suffer as a result should
there be any emergency
Mr Keith referred earlier to the impact
of EU exit preparations
and on the 22nd of January 2020 the
pandemic flew subgroup acknowledged that
due to the lack of work done and impact
on staff resources because of the EU
exit preparations that Northern Ireland
was more than 18 months behind the rest
of the UK in terms of ensuring
sector resilience to any pandemic flew
York pick
a millennium Mr Keith's remarks were
made in terms of the UK generally and it
appears from that that we were even 18
months behind that again
I mentioned Brenda Doherty Melody her
mother as you heard Ruth Burke died on
the 24th of March 2020. she was the
fourth person to die from covet in
Northern Ireland the first woman
she was admitted to hospital on the 11th
of March because of high levels of
warfarin
there was no testing of patients on
admission
the only PPE she saw was a disposable
apron
she asked the staff about covid-19
because she'd seen footage of it on
television
and with of events in China and Mainland
Europe
she was told not to worry it will all be
over by the summer
on the 19th of March she arrived at the
hospital and was told visiting was being
stopped
put a nurse let her in for five minutes
at the end of the five months her mother
asked why she was leaving
she said she couldn't stay because of
the coronavirus restrictions
she told her mom that she'd be home soon
and that they all loved her
she waved bye-bye and that was the last
she saw of her mother
on the 23rd of March
she made a phone call to the hospital
but was told that only limited
information could be given on the phone
but but of course Malaysia there was no
other way to get information
half an hour after that
the Prime Minister announced the
lockdown restrictions
she then later received a call asking if
she agreed to know unnecessary
intervention in relation to her mother
and she thought that that's it is she
going to make it
can the family be there
and she was told no
12 hours later she received a phone call
to say that her mother had passed away
without any of her family being by her
side
the walls as she said my lady no coming
home
no seeing her and her coffin
no Lane out of her clothes for her to be
laid to rest in
the funeral she described
she waited outside blocked Cemetery
Gates for the hearse to arrive there was
no carrying of the coffin
console workers
were dressed in white clothes and there
was red and white tip around the grave
it all lasted 15 minutes a committed she
describes that ours rather than a
funeral
and afterwards they all walked back
separately to their own houses
that's one story my lady but
the themes in that story and Other
Stories referred to and the other people
in Mr hardy and Brenda Doherty's
statement are there
and then
the themes of lack of communication
that not only did these people suffer
the death of their loved ones from covid
and in high proportion the elderly and
the vulnerable
people who should have been protected
and like so many others her mother was
given covet in hospital
preparedness should be
meaning
the protection of the most vulnerable
from death
but also preparedness
ought to have contemplated
prepared for and prevented
unnecessary or disproportionate
dehumanizing
thank you
re-traumatizing restrictions
so many of our families malaria are
picking up the pieces
from this clinical estrangement in the
Final Phase of their loved ones lives
no wake
human remains treated like toxic waste
Melody preparedness and resilience
is not just about science
it's about
anticipating and minimizing the
holistic overall impact of a pandemic
and it's
containment and eradication the impact
of that on human beings
malaria our families know that there's
no other person better equipped and
suited with the forensic expertise and
compassion to deliver the truth for the
families of what happened
both in this module and the modules to
come
thank you very much for listening to us
today thank you very much indeed
made some very important points thank
you very much
um
I shall right now
and return it
five plus ten past two
sorry
I think we may have to reconvene it too
only because we've got quite a number of
opening skills okay so sorry
um
completely misreading the clock forgive
me everybody uh return at two o'clock
foreign
Miss heaven
good afternoon my lady good afternoon
I represent the covid-19 bereaved
families for justice Camry and as you
know we've submitted detailed written
submissions which we understand will be
published on the inquiries website today
the country group is dedicated solely to
campaigning for truth justice and
accountability for those bereaved by
covid-19 in Wales the country group is
led by Anna Louise Marsh Reese Sam Smith
Higgins and Liz Grant and it's Guided by
the concerns of its bereaved members
across Wales it is committed to giving a
voice to all of those in Wales who are
bereaved due to covid-19 and to ensuring
that there is proper scrutiny of all
government decision making relevant to
Wales including those decisions made in
Westminster and by the Welsh government
in Wales
Milady as you know from the time that
you spent visiting Wales prior to the
commencements of these hearings the
people in Wales have experienced and
continue to experience suffering and
Trauma due to the devastation caused by
covid-19
as you will also have been told no doubt
on many occasions many of those breathed
feet people feel that they were let down
by their government
they feel let down because they have
experienced firsthand the consequences
of what they consider to be the
catastrophic failure of the Welsh
government to adequately prepare for and
respond to a pandemic in Wales
I will touch on just a few of the
stories relevant to module one but of
course there are many many stories of
loss which you will hear as part of
every story matters
like many parts of the United Kingdom
many people in Wales lost loved ones in
Care Homes receiving patients from
overwhelmed local NHS Wales hospitals
where those Care Homes had inadequate
isolation and inadequate personal
protective equipment PPE
the numbers of those dying in Wales due
to hospital acquired covid-19 was
exceptionally High
and in many cases this was in the
context of well-known inadequate
um and poor infection control and again
a lack of PPE
many of those hospitals as I said were
known to have inadequate ventilation
many members of the Camry group have
professional experience working in
sectors heavily impacted by covid-19 and
they experienced shocking conditions as
workers on the front line
they saw firsthand the failures and
deficiencies in the Welsh government's
pandemic preparedness risk management
and civil contingencies planning
the Conway group have valuable
first-hand experience to offer the
inquiry and they welcome the opportunity
to participate and give oral evidence
and they continue to offer you their
full support and it is hope that the
inquiry continues to hear as many of the
voices of the Welsh grieved as possible
now unlike Scotland as you know Wales
has not been granted its own public
inquiry by the Welsh government
this inquiry is therefore the only
opportunity the people of Wales will
have to ensure that there is proper
scrutiny of the decisions of the Welsh
government and their advisors in the
planning and response to the covid-19
pandemic
the people of Wales are looking for
answers
they are also looking for accountability
and for failures to be acknowledged so
that lessons can be learned
in the early days of this inquiry the
comrie group the UK government the
Senate and indeed this inquiry itself
received repeated assurances from the
first Minister for Wales Mark Drakeford
and the Welsh government that they were
committed to fully engaging with this
inquiry
it is against this background that Mark
Drakeford as first Minister maintained
and continues to maintain that there is
no need for Wales to hold its own public
inquiry
Mark Drakeford reminded the right
honorable Boris Johnson MP as he then
was as prime minister that quote I would
invite you to agree that all public
bodies engaging with the inquiry are
expected to consider themselves under a
duty of candor
that Duty should drive their culture of
Engagement with the inquiry and should
lead to prompt and comprehensive
disclosure of all relevant material to
the inquiry
the duty of Candor should also guide the
way public body Witnesses should
approach the inquiry
the country group do therefore formally
wish to say today that they are very
disappointed by what they consider to be
the inadequate response and engagement
by the Welsh government with this
inquiry in module one
in earlier hearings core participants
were told by your Council of the inquiry
Mr Keith Casey about the fact that the
Welsh government had submitted first
statements containing assertions which
were not supported by documentary
evidence
having received the Final witness
statements submitted by the Welsh
government and their advisors the Camry
group remained frankly shocked by the
brevity and lack of detail in some of
those statements
it also appears very disappointing that
in some quarters there appears to be a
reluctance by certain ministers to take
political responsibility for failures to
prepare for a pandemic in Wales
as you know the comrie group was so
concerned with the brevity and gaps in
the statements submitted to this inquiry
by first Minister for Wales Mark
Drakeford that they raised those
concerns directly with your inquiry
legal team
and it is important that I briefly touch
on some of those concerns today so that
the Welsh public who we know are
listening intently are aware of what
appears to be missing from this
statement
an outline Mark drakeford's statement is
exceptionally brief and it only deals
with the period of pandemic preparation
for where Mark Drakeford was appointed
as first Minister for Wales in 2018.
crucially it
fails to cover in any detail the
extended period from 2009 when Mark
Drakeford was involved in health and
local government policy both as a
special advisor to the first Minister
and a minister of the Welsh government
and crucially it fails to mention that
as first Minister for Wales from
December 2018 to the current day Mark
Drakeford is head of and responsible for
oversight over pandemic planning in
Wales as the chair of the Wales
resilience forum
the statement provided by Carwin Jones
who of course is a former first minister
of Wales from 2009 to 2018 so that's
nine years
which are clearly within the remit of
this inquiry
contains just over four pages on
pandemic planning
my lady on any view these are
fundamental and significant emissions
which leave this inquiry in the bereaved
in Wales at this stage with a
significant Gap in fully understanding
the state of knowledge and decision
making and ultimately political
accountability in relation to pandemic
planning in Wales
it is hoped therefore that moving
forward there will be a full commitment
from the Welsh government to provide
complete and timely disclosure and to
providing as much detail as possible on
the questions that you ask Witnesses in
your rule 9 requests
now the comrie group consider that the
critical questions that the inquiry must
closely scrutinize in relation to Wales
are as follows
what did the Welsh government know and
not know in the period under
consideration by the inquiry
what should the Welsh government have
known and what different and better
decisions could have been taken by the
Welsh government and their advisors
the country group considered that the
following propositions appear even now
reflected in the evidence before this
inquiry and we have addressed these in
much more detail in our written opening
submissions
the country group consider that pandemic
planning in Wales was the responsibility
of the Welsh government and not the UK
government
for the avoidance of doubt it seems to
the comrie group that the first Minister
for Wales had ultimate responsibility
and oversight for pandemic planning in
Wales as chair of the Welsh resilience
forum
the comrie group consider that pandemic
planning preparedness and resilience in
Wales was wholly inadequate and that
includes oversight and enforcement in
relation to implementing pandemic
recommendations
the evidence before the inquiry even at
this early stale stage reveals that the
Welsh government and their advisors had
sufficient notice knowledge and warnings
of the risks to the lives of people in
Wales from a pandemic
including a SARS pandemic but that they
failed to take adequate steps to prepare
and build resilience and I'll just touch
upon a few examples
whilst Wales held its own formal
planning exercises so that's talies in
2009 cygnus 2014 and public health Wales
Dromedary 2015
these exercises appear bureaucratic and
merely designed to satisfy
administrative requirements rather than
address the substance of pandemic
planning
in terms of the adequacy of that
planning exercise cygnus in 2014 tested
the pan Wales response plan in Wales
however the outcome document is
extremely brief and makes no mention of
testing for NHS Wales surge capacity for
example
PPE or RP demands and stockpiling
there's no mention of the impact of
restrictions on free movement there's no
mention of Workforce resilience just to
pick out a few examples
Wales did not formally plan for the
impact of any lockdown measures but
tested them only after covid-19 had
arrived in the United Kingdom
whereas England tested for surge
capacity it appeals that Wales did not
however
one of the most significant failures on
the part of the Welsh government was
only planning for an influenza pandemic
to the exclusion of planning for other
viruses with pandemic potential
this was a catastrophic and
unjustifiable failure
not only had the Welsh government been
warned about a very high death toll from
a flu pandemic in the Years prior to
covid-19 but there'd also been two
coronavirus pandemics in the 21st
century SARS and the Middle East
Respiratory Syndrome
the inquiry is asked to pay close
attention to the witness statement and
that has been provided to you from the
covid-19 Airborne transmission Alliance
which systematically dismantles the
floor in the UK and by extension the
Welsh government's failure to engage in
long-term planning for an aerosol
transmitted SARS virus
the comrie group endorse and support the
crucial work and Analysis that has been
carried out by the covid-19 Airborne
transmission Alliance
so what about the implementation of
Lessons Learned From pandemic planning
groups in Wales
there were there were a profusion of
bodies apparently engaging in pandemic
planning in Wales similar to the other
devolved Nations and indeed to the
United Kingdom
for example we've got the Welsh
resilience Forum we've got the local
resilience forums we've got the health
emergency planning group The Wales risk
group the emergency planning Advisory
Group the mash casualty group the
training and exercise group and the
Wales pandemic flu and preparedness
group and it goes on
but what are these groups actually doing
the welshbury vast
for example were they communicating with
any administrations outside Wales
whilst there were clearly updates and
tweaks to pandemic plans in Wales over
the years you were considering the
reality is is that it was minimal and it
was inadequate
there appears to be no evidence that all
the groups that I have just mentioned
and indeed many more
that the former Welsh pandemic exercises
led to material changes to Wales level
of preparedness and resilience
Welsh hospitals continued with poor
ventilation
there was no planning and preparation in
Wales for responding to a sudden surge
in demand in the social care system
there were inadequate measures taken to
refresh or maintain sufficient levels of
PPE and other protective equipment
stockpiles
in other words there appears to have
been inadequate implementation even for
a serious and catastrophic flu pandemic
let alone a pandemic such as covid-19
the Welsh government knew that they
needed to improve infection control and
the design and ventilation of Welsh
hospitals and Care Homes to reduce
infection it appears in many of their
very early documents that you have
before you
the Welsh government knew that they had
to stockpile pprp
but when the covid-19 pandemic hit there
was a shortage particularly of ffp3
respiratory masks and of course a PPE
the Welsh government knew they had to
plan for xsds from a pandemic including
the worst case scenario and the figures
in the documents are 210 to 315 100
000 excess deaths nationally in 15 weeks
there is no evidence of a plan or a
strategy to deal with excess deaths or
the consequences
to take one small example there is no
evidence for planning for sufficient
body bags and Storage
there appears to be no evidence of
adequate planning in relation to
post-desh procedures to protect dignity
and to support the Welsh grieved in the
event of a pandemic and this single
failure caused Untold suffering in Wales
the Welsh government knew many years
before covid-19 struck that there would
be a significant burden on Care Homes
and the care sector and on the
vulnerable in the event of a pandemic
and again Milady when you look closely
at some of the very earliest Welsh
planning documents you will see those
concerns raised
yet there is no evidence that shows
these areas were actually addressed in
any real or substantive way
in 2016 exercise cygnus revealed that
quote the UK's current preparedness and
response in terms of its plans policies
and capability is currently not
sufficient to cope with the extreme
demands of the severe pandemic which
will have a nationwide impact across all
sectors
so the question that one of the
questions that the inquiry must consider
is why there had been such a failure in
preparedness and resilience prior to
2016 and in particular in Wales from our
clients perspective
after the warning from cygnus in 2016
the Camry group want to know whether the
Welsh government then acted fast enough
and seriously enough to prioritize
pandemic planning in the way that it
warranted
if brexit or a lack of sufficient budget
from the United Kingdom government is to
be used on it as an excuse by the Welsh
government for not protecting the people
of Wales from a pandemic
the inquiry is asked to ascertain how
the Welsh government sought to address
such funding issues
for example did the Welsh government
consistently ask the UK government for
more money after daily Evolution for
pandemic planning
did the Welsh government tell the people
of Wales and their Senate that because
of devolution they did not have the
resources to adequately prepare for a
pandemic and protect the people of Wales
it is now accepted in the statement of
Dr Frank Atherton Wales is chief medical
officer since 2016 that Wales did plan
failed to plan for long-lasting pandemic
and quote the plans were inadequate for
a two or three year shock to the system
the comrie group considered that this
concession simply does not go far enough
the truth is that the Welsh plans were
wholly inadequate for any widespread and
potentially fatal pandemic likely to
result in high numbers of deaths and
requiring restrictions wide-ranging use
of protecting equipment or wide-scale
hospitalization
so the question is why did this happen
and
Milady we and indeed you are now
beginning to see an explanation emerging
in the evidence before the inquiry
if we look at implementation and
oversight of pandemic related
recommendations in Wales
reg Kirkpatrick the director general for
covid coordination and from 2013 head of
Welsh government civil contingencies and
emergency planning which of course
included pandemic planning has now told
this inquiry that quote taking forward
every recommendation has been
challenging against other more immediate
priorities but we have endeavored to
turn leaving
learning into best practice where we can
and change structures and processes
where required for the better
form gething Minister responsible for
health care in Wales
has admitted that he did not even check
whether the learning from exercise
cygnus 2016 had been implemented but
rather he states that he quote assumed
any absent any advice to the country or
questions in the Senate that the lessons
of exercise sickness had been applied
Mark Drakeford gives a similar answer in
his statement to this inquiry namely
quote I do not recall any advice from
officials that there were any
reservations about the state of Wales is
pandemic preparedness nor did I recall
any concerns in the Senate being raised
with me
it is deeply shocking to the country
group that those with political
responsibility for protecting people in
Wales former pandemic did not consider
it their job to understand and check the
state of pandemic preparedness and
resilience in Wales
instead there now seems to be a distinct
attempt to shift responsibility for the
oversight of pandemic planning
implementation
onto civil servants and the seneth
the comrie group considered that this
gives the inquiry an insight into the
Welsh government's approach to pandemic
planning in the years before covid-19
and their willingness now to accept some
responsibility for what went wrong
in terms of risks arising in the event
of a pandemic
the Welsh government knew from before
and during the period under
consideration by this inquiry that a
pandemic was right at the top of the UK
National Security risk register
however those responsible for pandemic
planning in Wales do not appear to have
taken sufficient steps to understand and
plan for the risks of a pandemic as they
would present in Wales
as now acknowledged by reg Kirkpatrick
the National Security risk register
contained assessment which quote provide
information at a UK level of analysis
rather than one one which would serve
the Welsh government
Mr Kirkpatrick now accepts that quote
understanding threat and risk at a more
disaggregated level is essential to
effective preparedness
and as a result he now explains that
Wales has its own Wales risk register
however risk in Wales
ought to have been properly understood
in detail by the Welsh government at the
time and the country group do ask the
inquiry to get to the bottom of whether
or not there was in fact a Welsh risk
register in place during the relevant
period under consideration
the simple fact is that Wales and the
Welsh government
did not have an adequate understanding
of the risks posed to the people of
Welsh from a pandemic before and during
the relevant period and this led to much
more severe consequences from covid-19
for vulnerable groups and communities in
Wales
for example pandemic preparedness failed
to take account of the acute Health
inequalities in Wales distinct from the
rest of the United Kingdom
and that specifically includes levels of
chronic ill health and disability in the
older population
professors bambra and Sir Michael Marmot
in their report indicate that
pre-existing Health inequalities were
considered in no more than in a minimal
way in the devolved administrations and
even in UK pandemic planning
the Welsh government should have sought
to understand and incorporate
considerations of Health inequalities
that existed in Wales into its pandemic
planning as soon as they had the power
to do so which of course was after the
evolution in 1999
my lady when you consider the
explanations that will be offered to you
by the Welsh government as to why they
could not fall fully and adequately
build resilience and prepare for a
pandemic in Wales you just need to bear
in mind that the Welsh government have
had 24 years since Devolution to plan
for such a pandemic in a way that best
protected the most vulnerable and
disadvantaged in our society
there are many other vitally important
topics that the Conway group ask you to
scrutinize which reasons of time can't
be covered in detail in these
submissions today but in brief these
include intergovernmental political
relations between Wales and the United
Kingdom government
the coordination between the United
Kingdom government and the Welsh
government and their medical and
scientific advisors
variation in standards in the approach
to planning and preparation
the investment in resilience of and the
resilience of people and the systems in
Wales for example the adequacy of
training information technology and NHS
Wales digitization and data sharing and
finally planning in relation to
post-desk procedures as I've said to
protect the dignity and to support the
Welsh bereaved in the event of a
pandemic
so in conclusion the can we group very
strongly believed that there was a
failure to adequately prepare and build
resilience in Wales for a pandemic and
that this caused unnecessary pain
suffering and ultimately death
through their own experiences the Camry
group know only too well that in Wales
there were many preventable deaths from
covert 19.
the Conway group considered that the
Welsh government must now acknowledge
what went wrong
this is vital to ensure that lessons are
learned from the experience of covid-19
in Wales so that when the next pandemic
arrives Welsh lives are better protected
the Welsh government must now make a
genuine commitment to long-term pandemic
planning thank you
thank you very much indeed for seven
very grateful
Dr Mitchell Casey
I'm instructed by solicitor Amar Anwar
on behalf of the Scottish covert
bereaved my learner Juniors Kevin
McCaffrey and Kevin Henry assist me
along with the solicitors team Moran
Warren Company
in writing on the great flu the
influenza pandemic of 1918.
Albert Martin emitted his professor of
history at Yeshiva University wrote in
when the next pandemic comes as it
surely will someday perhaps we will be
ready to meet it
if we are not the outcome will be very
very very Dreadful
the inquiry will come to hear that the
UK
and Scotland was not prepared
that the capacity of the UK to cope with
and recover quickly from difficulties
caused by covid was diminished by years
of changes to critical establishment
underfunding cuts failures to address
inequality and the effects of brexit
despite a belief that the UK was a world
leader in preparedness it quickly and
terrifyingly became clear
that we were not
the fact is at best those in charge
sought to prepare for the wrong pandemic
whilst it may be true that in planning
for a pandemic there are of course areas
of supposition and hypothesis what ought
to have been clear is that years of
austerity and the effects of brexit had
left the UK woefully underprepared for
the virus that swept our Shores
the inquiry will come to hear from all
of our electron Minister for government
policy
2010-2016 inquiry reference zero zero
zero one seven seven eight one zero at
paragraph eight
he States
as we as we all now know in the event we
were much better prepared to deal with
the pandemic influenza that we did not
face than we were to deal with the
covid-19 that we did face
the inquiry will also hear from Matt
Hancock Secretary of State for Health
and Social care July 2018 to June 2021
inquiry statement zero zero zero one
eight one eight two five at paragraph
six
on coming into posters Health secretary
I was advised that the UK was a world
leader in preparations for the pandemic
whilst this may have been a heartfelt
belief it did not turn out to be the
case when faced with what became known
as covert 19.
once we understood the threat from the
disease
the lack of concrete preparedness plans
became clear
according to the National records of
Scotland as at 4th June 2023 there were
646 deaths in Scotland were covid-19 was
mentioned on the death certificate
many of those who have died because of
poor mental health as a result of the
effects of the pandemic will not be
recorded as covert deaths although is
equally to blame
the same can be said for those who
couldn't access medical services which
might have saved their lives
the true cost the true human cost of
covert cannot be calculated in numbers
each of these deaths not only represents
an individual tragedy but has affected
friends and family loved ones colleagues
neighbors of each one who died
no one in the UK has been unaffected by
the pandemic
Scottish covered bereave began as part
of a Facebook group
they now represent a group of
like-minded bereaved individuals who
share common goals
not wanting the deaths of their loved
ones to have been in vain and for
lessons to be learned by governments and
public authorities to ensure that no one
else will have to suffer in the same way
as its members have
the Scottish covered bereaved are
certain that in Sharing lived
experiences both throughout the pandemic
and afterwards they will greatly assist
the chair in understanding the impact of
the pandemic and the response how
decisions affecting every individual
were made and the lessons which can and
must be learned to ensure we're all
better prepared to face any future
pandemic
while Scottish Covered Bridge came
together as a result of their shared
experience of suffering bereavement due
to the pandemic their membership
includes those with experience of other
consequences of the pandemic healthcare
workers who are on the front line of the
response to covert 19.
many of whom continue to suffer from
trauma as a result of their experiences
members of ethnic minorities who suffer
as a result of inequalities in health
sufferers have long covered who continue
to be affected by a lack of medical
knowledge of and treatment for the
condition
relatives of an individual who died
after having contracted covid-19 while
unvaccinated in custody illustrating
issues of vaccine rollout in the prison
setting and the provision of health care
for those individuals
although diverse in experience the
Scottish covered bereaved are united in
their commitment to ensure that this
inquiry carries out its task properly in
this module and assesses whether the
pandemic was properly planned for and
whether the UK was adequately ready for
the eventuality
my little friend Mr Keith Casey in his
opening speech set out many questions
that the inquiry will consider and those
questions are welcomed by the Scottish
covered bereaved
here are some further questions that
they want answers to
why were crucial questions not learned
from the
2002-2004 SARS outbreak the 2012 mares
outbreak and the pandemic planning
exercises
why was the stock of PPE which had been
built up and stockpiled at considerable
expense since the swine flu epidemic of
2009 not properly monitored for the
expiry of items and why were they
necessary Replacements not ordered why
according to Media reports were millions
of items of expired PPE readmitted to
the stockpile and relabeled with new
expiry dates over the old what does this
say of the UK's preparedness for a
pandemic
where the politicians from the UK and
involved in Ministry devolved
administrations able to put aside
political differences and to act in a
public interest
was our NHS in Scotland properly staffed
and resourced to allow it to deal with
the pandemic of this magnitude where our
social service about our social care
services properly staffed and resourced
where our Public Health institutions
properly funded and structured to allow
them to deal with the pandemic
these questions in this module represent
only a tiny number of the many questions
that in the future will need to be
answered
like did our politicians ignore the
science until it was too late why were
Scotland's chief medical officers senior
nursing officers and many others not
invited to important Siege meetings
who decided on the deadly steps of
releasing untested people into care
homes from hospitals whilst relatives
despite having proof of negative covert
tests were truly denied the right to
visit their relatives
why did Downing Street delay the
lockdown what was the scientific
justification for Russia next eat out to
help out scheme why were our governments
so slow in acting on asymptomatic and
aerosol generator transmission despite
scientific evidence
today it will be over three years since
the first death from covid-19 took place
in this country and that time probably
nearly quarter of a million people have
died either directly or indirectly from
covid as our leaders now Stand Accused
of presiding over a carousel of Chaos
in the coming weeks months and years the
mantra for some who will give evidence
this inquiry will be with the benefit of
hindsight
our government had been tasked with
preparing for a pandemic for decades
for a few brief moments in the pandem
the pandemic death sparked a universal
grief as we were asked to unite behind
our nation's politicians and stand on
doorsteps but very quickly we were asked
to move on
now is the time for careful reflection
those who lost loved ones will no longer
be invisible in their misery and it's
for this inquiry to eliminate the truth
of what's happened and why
over the coming months and years at
times this inquiry May falter but it
cannot feel it will come under sustained
unreputed attacks it will suffer legal
challenges in its quest to obtain the
evidence it needs to shed light on
what's happened
it must however never be afraid to raise
its voice for the truth that's the very
least we owe to those who lost their
lives and to those in the future who may
be saved by the implementation of this
inquiry's findings
the work of this inquiry May save many
more lives in the next pandemic than all
the preparation that was undone in
advance of the covert pandemic
governments would do be able to remember
this when they fail to provide
information requested by this inquiry
no person no institution no matter how
powerful whether it be in England
Scotland Wales or Northern Ireland
Westminster Hollywood can obstruct the
search for truth
the Scottish covert believe have and
will tell their heartbreaking stories
we will question our leaders our civil
servants our physicians because further
believe the words truth and change must
be the legacy of this inquiry
across the United Kingdom thousands felt
marginalized isolated betrayed and lied
to as the cries of the dying went
unheard it is for those thousands who
died who could no longer try out for
justice that the bereaved families fight
the Scottish covered belief welcomes the
commencement of the public hearing for
the UK inquiry and acknowledge the
massive amount of work done to date and
commend the determination of the inquiry
to uncover the truth and we intend to
fill our role as core participants to
support the inquiry in achieving that
end
it is not only in the interests of the
Scottish covert bereaved but it is in
the interest of every person in the
United Kingdom that this inquiry
understands what happened why it
happened and what can be done to ensure
that when the next pandemic comes as it
surely will someday we will be prepared
these are the submissions for the
Scottish covered bereaved thank you very
much indeed Dr Mitchell very grateful
right
um I think it looks like it's Mr Stanton
next
good afternoon my lady
I'm hoping we'll get away from this
having to wait for the lectern moving
across the room
my lady thank you for this opportunity
to address you
the opening statements on behalf of the
British Medical Association the BMA is
as follows
doctors and other healthcare workers
were on the front line of the UK's
response to covid-19 and they worked
tirelessly to treat and care for
patients with covid and those with other
health care needs
in doing this they put themselves at
increased risk from the disease itself
and from the stress and pressure of
working through a Public Health crisis
of this scale
for many doctors and other healthcare
workers deficiencies in pandemic
planning and resilience had and continue
to have a significant impact on their
day-to-day lives
an examination of a decade before the
pandemic and of the UK's Readiness is
essential to ensure the the UK is better
prepared in the future
the statement seeks to highlight four
key areas that the BMA considers should
be explored within the module one
hearings to assist the inquiry to
identify what went wrong
and to make appropriate recommendations
for much needed change and Improvement
it is based on the views and priorities
of the bmas membership including the
overriding priority of all doctors to
deliver the best care and treatment for
patients
the BMA has gathered extensive feedback
from its membership over the course of
the pandemic and since
and selected examples are included
within this statement to illustrate the
points made
first there was a failure to prepare
adequately for a range of pandemic
threats
the UK's pandemic planning was
predominantly focused on an
influenza-style pandemic
this narrow Focus was an oversight
particularly as there have been
relatively recent coronavirus outbreaks
including SARS in 2002 and MERS in 2012.
one consequence of the predominant focus
on an influenza-style pandemic was that
the UK's response to covid-19 failed to
properly consider the potential for
aerosol transmission of the virus
this in turn impacted the public health
measures put in place
including the focus on hand washing and
the delay mandating mask wearing for the
public
for doctors and other healthcare workers
the failure in considering aerosol
transmission resulted in insufficient
stocks of appropriate PPE
and inadequate infection prevention and
control in healthcare settings
as one doctor in Scotland said open
quote
the PPE guidance was based not on safety
but rather the lack of preparedness end
quote
shockingly this is this is the case even
now
the current IPC guidance continues to
put staff and patients at risk by
erroneously stating that fluid resistant
surgical masks are adequate protection
for healthcare workers carrying out
their carrying out routine care for
covert positive patients rather than
specifying respirators such as filtering
face piece respirators often referred to
as ffp2 and ffp3 masks
which are recommended by International
guidance
and by the BMA
the limitations of surgical masks were
well known prior to the pandemic
highlighted for example in a research
report by the health and safety
executive in 2008.
the HSE report noted that while surgical
masks May reduce residual aerosol risk
to some degree
they might not sufficiently reduce the
likelihood of transmission
and consequently surgical masks should
not be used in situations where close
exposure to infectious aerosols is
likely
this same 2008 report
also predicted the crisis of PPE Supply
including the following statement open
quote
the widespread use of respirators might
be difficult to sustain during a
pandemic unless provision is made for
their use in advance close quote
as the regulator entrusted with the
protection of worker Health the health
and safety executive will be in a
position to help the inquiry understand
what more should have been done to
mitigate the risks to workers of an
Airborne virus
the BMA has heard from countless doctors
who are concerned about the failure to
provide adequate protection including a
GP in Northern Ireland who complained
that there was open quote no attempt by
the Health and Social care board to
follow the science on Airborne
transmission and the need for staff to
have ffp3 masks and HEPA air filters
close quote
governments could and should have been
better prepared for the foreseeable
risks to doctors and Healthcare staff
this would have reduced the serious harm
that affected so many of the bma's
members and The Wider Healthcare
Workforce
many of whom are today still suffering
with long covered acquired in their
workplace
the second key area to highlight is in
respect of the failures to implement the
recommendations from pandemic planning
exercises
while the UK did carry out a planning
exercise based on a coronavirus exercise
Alice in 2016.
this exercise did not sufficiently
prepare for a wider range of infectious
disease threats
and crucially key lessons from this
exercise as well as transferable
learning
from pandemic influenza exercises were
not implemented
one of the most significant failures in
this regard again concerns the
availability and provision of
appropriate PPE
the recommendations from exercise Alice
exercise cygnus also in 2016 an exercise
Iris in 2018
were to review current PPE stocks to
create a pandemic stockpile of PPE
to ensure staff had clear instruction
and training in the use of PPE and
infection control
and to develop a whole system approach
to distribute to PPE
however the failure to implement these
recommendations and to properly maintain
the PPE stockpiles before the pandemic
meant that PPE quickly ran out when
covid hit
and there was no effective plan in place
to replenish it through effective
procurement systems or local
manufacturing capacity
this led to many Healthcare staff being
forced to work unprotected from the
virus placing them at significant risk
the fact that in March 2020 NHS England
assured the Health and Social care
committee that there was sufficient
supply of PPE nationally
despite stocks containing less than two
weeks worth of most equipment suggests
serious failures of planning and
preparation
Frontline staff often had to go without
PPE by their own use homemade donated or
expired items and reuse single-use items
staff also had to use items that were
out of date with multiple expiry
stickers visibly layered on top of each
other
many felt pressured to work without
adequate protection with consequences
for their mental and physical health
in a BMA survey as part of its covid-19
review 81 percent of respondents
reported not feeling fully protected
during the first wave of the pandemic
and feeling worried or being fearful to
speak out about the lack of PPE
was more commonly reported by doctors
from an ethnic minority background and
those with a disability or long-term
health condition
commenting on the wholly inadequate
supply of of PPE a GP in Northern
Ireland said open quote
we were sent six pairs of gloves and six
aprons in an envelope approximately
three weeks after the start of lockdown
close quote
and a doctor in England recalled how
they open quote
made our own and bought our own when we
could find any we depended on Friends
sourcing ffp3 masks and my son's school
3D printing visors
close quote
these failures of planning and
preparation also led to PPE being
procured from from organizations with no
experience of manufacturing PPE
resulting in PPE being produced and
delivered that was unsuitable for use at
huge public expense
it also led to the ludicrous spectacle
of doctors making aprons from bin liners
because they were sturdier than the PPE
equipment provided
another serious failure to implement the
recommendations of planning exercises
included the identified need for further
work to ensure adequate contract tracing
and testing capacity
identified in exercise Iris
the UK made a number of decisions ahead
of and during the covid-19 pandemic in
relation to contact tracing which
hampered the response
little consideration was given within
pandemic planning policies and
strategies to detect and contain the
spread of the disease
but rather the emphasis was on how to
respond in a situation where there was
already significant mortality and
morbidity
for pandemic planning policies to be
comprehensive and effective both
strategies need full consideration
the decision to abandon contact tracing
on the 12th of March 2020
was ostensibly because the UK was moving
from the contain to the delay stage of
the pandemic
although it later emerged that this
decision was at least partly due to a
lack of capacity
contact racing was not reinstated for
several months with whale whales being
the last Nation to restart contact
racing on the 1st of June a critical
period during which there was sustained
transmission of the virus
these issues were compounded by a lack
of testing in the community and the NHS
the shortfall in testing capacity is
partly due to the UK government's
failure to utilize the 44 pre-existing
NHS Laboratories and an over-reliance on
both the private sector and the Seven
Lighthouse Laboratories
the expense and effort of using these
alternative Laboratories which operated
independently of Public Health and NHS
infrastructures and used different
software and systems was unnecessary and
created unhelpful fragmentation
the failure to adequately prepare for
the testing capacity that was needed
left healthcare workers and their
patients at increased risk of exposure
to covid-19
particularly at the beginning of the
pandemic
tests were not available for incoming
patients or even for staff themselves
as one Junior doctor in England told the
BMA open quote
there was a delay in allowing testing of
all patients with possible covered
symptoms
I was seeing patients in a e and being
told I could not test them because they
had not traveled to relevant countries
when testing was later allowed some of
these patients unsurprisingly ended up
testing positive
I saw these patients with no PPE due to
hospital rules around when PPE was
allowed to be worn
close quote
a failure a further failure to implement
key recommendations from planning
exercises is in respect of the need for
surge capacity in the Health Service
identified in exercise cygnus and
exercise Pica in 2018.
this issue is closely connected to the
next and third key area which is that
the public health system was not in a
position to scale up its activity to
respond to the pandemic due to a decade
or more of reduced funding resource cuts
and reorganizations that caused
fragmentation in the system
Public Health Systems across the UK
entered the pandemic without the
necessary resources Workforce capacity
and structures to respond at speed and
scale required
the reforms introduced in England by the
2012 Health and Social Care Act which
moved responsibility for public health
into local authorities
fractured the links between Public
Health Specialists and NHS colleagues
meaning communication and information
sharing was compromised during the
pandemic
one Public Health doctor told the BMA
that open quote
the separation of Public Health into
local authorities and public health
England
meant that Pub that many public health
consultants and teams in local
authorities became de-skilled in health
Protection work
this put a huge burden on the whole
Workforce
with health protection Consultants
having to manage the majority of the
response and provide detailed guidance
and support to local Authority
colleagues who felt unconfident and
unprepared for dealing with infectious
disease outbreaks close quote
the reforms also left Public Health
Services vulnerable to Cuts in local
Authority spending settlements and the
years preceding the pandemic
this decline in funding has coincided
with a decline in the size of the public
health Workforce
and to meet the faculty of public
Health's recommendation from 2021 for
the number of full-time equivalent
Public Health Specialists per capita
the workforce would need to increase by
59 in England 32 percent in Scotland 18
in Wales and 97 in Northern Ireland
the fourth and final key area to
highlight is that the UK entered the
pandemic with poor population Health
widening Health inequalities and Health
Services that have been consistently
underfunded and understaffed
in order to holistically assess the
state of the UK's preparedness
it is also important to consider the
high levels of population ill health and
health inequalities
before anyone had heard of covid-19
gains in life expectancy a key measure
of our nation's Health had already
started to stall
while Health inequalities were widening
after a decade of austerity
severe cuts to Public Health Service and
Social Security funding amounting to
billions of pounds since 2010
have negatively impacted the
availability of services that are
essential for good population health
this in turn hindered the UK's ability
to respond effectively to the covid-19
pandemic
they had also there had also been a
marked deterioration within Health and
Care Systems in the decade leading up to
the covid-19 pandemic caused by a
failure to invest to ensure adequate
capacity Staffing and infrastructure
for instance the UK went into the
pandemic with a very low total number of
hospital beds relative to its population
and very low numbers of ICU Beds which
significantly hampered its ability to
cope with the number of patients needing
hospitalization with covid
this combined with Workforce shortages
and already high waiting lists meant
that the Health Service had no ability
to step up capacity to cope with the
increased demand from covid-19 alongside
the continuation of existing services
as one consultant in England told the
BMA open quote
being under strength to begin with in
terms of Staffing and already working
with bed occupancy at or above 100
percent
pre-pandemic meant no Headroom for
managing the eventual large increase in
demand that came
close quote
these failures to ensure a resilient
well-resourced Health and Care System
were brutally exposed by the pandemic
and the systems are now in an even worse
state with more people waiting for care
than ever a staggering 7.4 million
patients in England alone
unsafe bed occupancy levels acute
Staffing shortages neglected
infrastructure and deteriorating
equipment
this in the bma's view is the elephants
in the room when considering issues of
planning preparation and resilience
unless it is acknowledged and addressed
the same mistakes are destined to be
repeated
thank you madly thank you very much
indeed Mr Stanton
Mr Jacobs
thank you
good afternoon my lady I appear on
behalf of the Trade union Congress the
Tec instructed by Thompson solicitors
the TUC brings together five and a half
million working people who make up its
48 member unions and to span a wide
range of sectors profoundly affected by
the covid-19 pandemic
in this module the TUC is working in
partnership with the Wales TUC the
Scottish TUC and the Northern Ireland
Committee of the Irish Congress of trade
unions
the Scottish Tec and the Irish Congress
of trade unions are separate
organizations to the TUC but with shared
purposes and aims and together we seek
to represent the interests in this
inquiry of a great many unions all
listed in our written opening right
across the four nations of the UK
my lady I start with three points of
context
the first is that of loss and sacrifice
given our interests we focus on the loss
and sacrifice during the pandemic of the
working population
those in Health and Social care were
true truly on the front line of a
national emergency
of course so many others also kept the
country going those who stacked our
shelves who drove the buses and trains
so that key workers could attend work
who delivered Parcels to our doors who
worked the production line so food and
necessary Goods could continue to be
produced who cleaned our transport and
public buildings and so many others
far too many died
in the period march to December 2020
alone there were eight thousand deaths
of working age people related to covert
19.
those occupations with the highest death
rates over that period were the
elementary occupations caring Leisure
and other service occupations and
processed plants and machine operatives
the factors driving the difference in
death rates are multifactorial certainly
it appears to have been those in jobs
with regular exposure to covid-19 and
those working in close proximity to
others that had higher death rates than
compared with the general working
population
but those occupations also intersect
with other factors of ethnicity low pay
and poverty insecure work poor housing
and higher rates of pre-existing health
conditions
significantly it was not just loss it
was avoidable loss
the inquiry will hear evidence that the
UK fed poorly in terms of death rates as
compared with countries of comparable
resource
the second point of context is to
reflect on the symbolic importance of
this inquiry having reached the first
day of its substantive hearings
it is an important inquiry if it is
effective it will bring truth and
understanding to many thousands who wish
to better understand the circumstances
that led to the deaths of loved ones
the inquiry will also be forward-looking
and will seek to learn lessons
if the country when confronted with the
next pandemic as it undoubtedly will has
the benefit of Lessons Learned From This
inquiry it is no hyperbole to say that
this inquiry has the opportunity to
reduce avoidable deaths by their
thousands
[Music]
it is also a challenging inquiry given
its scope and we take this moment to
commend the inquiry for having reached
substantive hearings in such a
comparatively short time frame my lady
we have not agreed on all matters but we
absolutely recognize the industry of the
inquiry team and its desire and yours to
get it right we are confident that much
good work has been done by this inquiry
to get it on its way
the third point of context is a less
positive one it concerns the openness
and Candor or lack of it of the current
Westminster government
the inquiry and more importantly the
public deserve openness and Candor from
those who govern during the pandemic and
to govern now
at the preliminary hearing in module 2
last Tuesday this inquiry made
absolutely clear yet again the
difficulties that have been created by
cabinet office refusals to provide
documents that this inquiry wants to see
a number of core participants shared
expressions of concern
the response of the cabinet office was a
letter of Friday refusing to provide any
of the disputed documents but pending
the judicial review that is to be heard
on the 30th of June or shortly
thereafter
it is refusing even to return Boris
Johnson's Diaries to him as it knows
that Mr Johnson intends to provide them
to the inquiry
Mr Johnson himself has been complaining
to the Times newspaper of the cabinet
office foot dragging in its responses to
the inquiry of wasting public time and
money by delaying inquiry and of
deliberately frustrating the inquiry's
work
my lady the infighting jars with the
terrible losses described in the impact
film that we watched this morning
the position taken by the cabinet office
is corrosive because it damages
confidence in this inquiry it's smacks
of having something to hide of fighting
tooth and nail to avoid revealing all to
the inquiry
fundamentally the judicial review will
not really solve anything but a point of
legal Construction
what the public want to know is not
whether the high court will force the
cabinet office to provide documents but
whether the cabinet office can approach
this inquiry not just now but going
forward with the spirit of openness and
Candor that we deserve
those in the cabinets either have the
will to respond openly to this inquiry
or they do not and that's not a question
that can be answered by the high court
it is a matter of regrets it appears to
us that these substantive hearings start
under something of a cloud
I turn to summarize my lady very briefly
six themes that we believe are emerging
in the evidence collected by this
inquiry in module one
just as the legacy of austerity
we believe this to be a central theme it
rests on a simple but inescapable truth
that public services stretch to Breaking
points by over a decade of budget cuts
will be severely impaired in their
ability to cope with the shock of a
National Emergency such as a pandemic
it will be a striking feature of the
evidence that so many witnesses from
across government particularly in the
devolved nations from those at the
center of Public Health Services and
Health and Social care and from a range
of professional organizations will
describe the disastrous consequences of
austerity
it impaired our national preparedness
and resilience in a number of ways it
certainly impacted the resilience and
capacity of Public Services
but it also exacerbated the Deep
structural Social and Health
inequalities that exist in our society
[Music]
Public Health Services have been
hollowed out and so services are less
able to address those inequalities
there is also a clear link between
economic deprivation and health
inequality but a series of welfare
benefit Cuts hit the poorest in society
particularly those with children and of
working age
since 2010 14 billion has been cut from
support to households through Social
Security and Welfare benefits
predominantly in the period 2010 to 2016
when David Cameron was prime minister
and George Osborne the chancellor
rates of in-work poverty have increased
going into the pandemic the UK was
suffering from deteriorating health and
widening Health inequalities
they meant that the Health and Social
care sectors were treating a population
with significant and growing health
problems
decreasing funding and increasing need
creates a perfect storm
it also meant that the impact of a
pandemic on many of the higher risk
occupations those who continue to attend
work and have exposure to the virus and
work in proximity with others in
elementary occupations processing plants
care occupations and others like the 57
year old Taxi Driver we heard about in
the film this morning
was an impact upon a working population
that already had worsening rather than
improving levels of Health
austerity also almost eradicated any
meaningful service able to enforce
health and safety in workplaces
the primary regulator for health and
safety in places of work is the health
and safety executive
in 10 years of austerity its government
funding dropped from 231 million each
year to 123 million
on the 11th of May 2020 as many had or
would returning to work Boris Johnson
sought to provide reassurance that the
HSC would be undertaking spot
inspections to make sure that businesses
were keeping employees safe
but that was a vacuous reassurance in
circumstances that austerity had left
the HSC so depleted in its resources
by early June 2020 the HSC had already
received over 6 000 additional concerns
from workers about social distancing and
other pandemic related matters but those
concerns resulted in the sum total of 47
physical inspections of workplaces and
one prohibition notice it was a
regulator utterly bereft of any teeth
the Lessons Learned in this inquiry as
to pandemic planning and preparedness
will no doubt be many and varied
but the Central and salutary lesson from
the pandemic should be a fundamental
re-evaluation of the critical importance
and value of our Public Services
specific planning for future pandemics
must rest on a foundation of Public
Services that are valued and adequately
funded
we agree with the observation made a few
moments ago that it is the elephant in
the room
the second theme is capacity in our
health care System
the impression of the NHS collapsing in
on itself under the weight of increased
demand and decreasing funding is
familiar
it would run hot each winter from Winter
flu let alone a novel Coronavirus
due to problems with funding Staffing
equipment bed spaces and waiting lists
the NHS in early 2020 did not have the
capacity to meet existing demand
um yet are not an urgent new one
it is a crisis which continues to
develop with NHS waiting lists reaching
7.33 million in March of this year a
Workforce burnt out by the demands of
the preceding years and vacancies at a
five-year High
if we are to fare better and prevent
such devastating loss of life in the
next Health Emergency appropriate levels
of funding and a long-term recovery
strategy must be implemented
the third theme is capacity and
resilience of our social care sector
prior to the pandemic plans for the NHS
to Surge capacity in an emergency Place
significant Reliance on the ability of
the social care sector to provide
additional bed capacity
but as with Healthcare the social care
sector has huge problems with capacity
and Staffing the evidence will also
indicate that it barely featured in
pandemic planning
the fourth theme
is fragmentation of our Public Services
the organizational structures of our
Public Health Services have in recent
years undergone near constant
reorganizations
this morning Mr Keith showed us a
helpful organogram
it provides a visual and striking
representation of a fragmented system
which looks much more like a bowl of
spaghetti
than a clear and coordinated framework
for a cogent national response
on behalf of the British Medical
Association fragmentation in healthcare
has just been described but is also an
acute problem in the social care sector
in Social care the problem has not been
so much one of repeated restructuring
and reorganization but one of the
neglect there has been no attempt to
structure at all
adult social care in England is now
provided by around 18 000 organizations
the overall Workforce is larger than
that in the NHS
1.54 million people work in adult social
care compared to 1.37 million in the NHS
yet there is no equivalent to NHS
England which seeks to provide some
strategy and direction to the sector
the TUC has repeatedly called for a
national social care forum to bring
together government unions employers
Commissioners and providers to
coordinate the delivery and development
of services and include the negotiation
of a much needed Workforce strategy
coordinating a national effort across a
hodgepodge of private organizations is
quite obviously impossible
in terms of data the inquiry will hear
that records in relation to the care
sector are vitally lacking at the
beginning of the pandemic no single
National Database existed and local
Authority records were incapable of
providing a clear picture of the number
of people needing social care or working
in the care sector nor their demographic
characteristics
it was not known and is in fact still
not known with any level of provision
sorry precision
how many Residential Care Homes were in
operation across the UK
the overall picture is of key functions
Central to pandemic response being
fragmented and spread across the NHS
Public Health England local authorities
a myriad of other agencies and the many
thousands of social care providers
without a clear means of national
oversight and coordination
the fifth theme is a failure of localism
the structure of the Civil contingencies
Act is to focus many of the
responsibilities for planning for
emergencies on local organizations as Mr
Keith describes this morning
there is much to value in effective
localized resilience mechanisms built on
strong local knowledge
but those local resilience mechanisms
were not only under-resourced but also
inadequately connected with national
preparedness exercises and National
decision making on non-pharmaceutical
interventions
the sixth theme is not so much a theme
that is emerging among amongst the
evidence but one that we are concerned
is not emerging it is pandemic
preparedness across the whole range of
workplaces
many of the highest risk occupations
were outside of healthcare and were in
the elementary occupations
in any pandemic there will be a need for
food to be produced for Parcels to be
delivered for transport to operate and
so on
preparedness for these sorts of sectors
is crucial it is where the virus can
spread if not managed appropriately it
is where the death rate was at its
highest and it is where much of the
unequal impact of a pandemic is felt
preparedness is a necessity for these
sectors too and achieving that objective
requires a focus of central government
and local authorities
these sectors operate very substantially
in the private sector and so the demands
of preparedness and pandemic response
are different
it must be a responsibility of
government in planning for a pandemic to
identify where they will likely be a
need to step into support Industries
including on matters such as the
procurement of PPE many sectors on the
front line were without necessary PPE
for significant periods
this inquiry should consider in this
module the extent to which pandemic
planning considered such issues
there also needs to be effective
mechanisms for joint working between
government and the relevant Industries
including unions
the inquiry in this module and certainly
in module 2 will hear of differences in
this respect between the devolved
Nations
in England the arrangements for working
with professional and representative
organizations across sectors are limited
elsewhere particularly in Wales there is
an approach of social partnership in
which there were pre-existing and
improving structures to enable
partnership working between the
government and industries
that is critical on matters such as the
production of adequate workplace
guidance and the government being able
to quickly be alerted and respond to
challenges faced in different workplaces
repeatedly in the pandemic guidance
documents affecting millions of work
were produced with virtually no notice
or consultation
there is also crucially a need for fair
work
many Frontline workers who face the
highest death rates were in low-paid
jobs with poor employment rights one of
the most important non-pharmaceutical
interventions was self-isolation but
those working for example in a
processing plant will very often face
the difficulties of being in insecure
work of experiencing in-work poverty and
have at most a right to extremely
limited sick pay if anything
for many self-isolation would be a
choice between not self-isolating or
self-isolating but not having the money
to live and eat
the TUC has raised repeated concerns
about the limitations of statutory sick
pay and repeatedly raise it during the
pandemic in connection with the
effectiveness of self-isolation
the government response on sick pay was
unplanned for and late
it was also half-hearted in the single
month of the etap to help out scheme the
government spent 840 million on
supporting dining out
the following month local authorities
were given only 50 million to fund the
self-isolation supports payment scheme
to support the many thousands of key
workers on low pay who would struggle to
live if they were to self-isolate
my lady that is our opening and of
course there is more detail in our
written opening
finally one theme of this module will be
resilience of services
it may be my lady that you having
courageously reached the foothills of
this inquiry another reservoir of
resilience upon which we are dependent
is yours and we stand ready to resist
assist rather
a key difference thank you very much
uh on the basis of resist resilience I
think we all need a break so um I should
be back
uh just after half past 15 minutes from
now please
foreign
right um I think we have Miss manaham
who needs to get a flight
that is correct my lady uh good
afternoon uh I make this opening
statement on behalf of the Northern
Ireland Department of Health which I'll
refer to in the course of the statement
as being the department
the purpose my lady of this opening
statement is to outline the evidence
that has and will be given in respect of
the systems the structures and the
processes relevant to pandemic
preparedness in Northern Ireland
I wish to begin by conveying the
Department's sincere condolences to
those who have suffered bereavement as a
result of the covid-19 pandemic
the department also expresses its
sympathy and support for everyone across
the country who is living with or who
has suffered from this disease
the department extends its sincere
condolences to those who have lost loved
ones who or who have had their lives
turned upside down by this disease
In Our Lifetime this crisis was
unprecedented and the pandemic had a
direct and dramatic impact on the daily
lives of every single occupant of these
islands
the department acknowledges the huge
losses that many amongst us have
suffered and in some cases continue to
suffer
the department also wishes to emphasize
its gratitude to and support for health
care workers
the department has an extraordinary
appreciation and respect for health care
workers who during this pandemic
selflessly put their lives on the line
to protect the whole of the community
these health care workers unflinchingly
acted for the benefit of us all in times
of great uncertainty and danger and for
that we thank them sincerely
I also take this opening statement as an
opportunity to clarify some of the
important aspects of the structure of
the department and the Health and Social
care system in Northern Ireland
Department's key key statutory
responsibilities arise on foot of the
Health and Social care Reform Act
Northern Ireland 2009.
these core responsibilities are to
promote an integrated system of Health
and Social care so as to ensure
Improvement in the physical and mental
health of people in Northern Ireland in
the prevention the diagnosis and the
treatment of illness and in the social
well-being of people in Northern Ireland
accordingly the department is
responsible for Health and Social care
legislation and policy and is the lead
government department for responding to
health consequences of emergencies
it was in this role that the department
assumed responsibility for the health
response to the covid-19 pandemic
the department is headed by a permanent
secretary
the role of the permanent secretary in
the department is to act as the
principal accounting officer and the
principal advisor to the minister for
help
another important aspect of the
department structures is that until
April 2022 it had 17 arms length bodies
these arms length bodies help the
department achieve its objectives
however in March 2022 one of those arms
length bodies namely the Health and
Social care board was dissolved and its
functions were transferred back into the
department
those functions now reside within the
newly established strategic planning and
performance group that is held within
the department
the functions therefore of the
department and its arms length bodies
are often referred to by the umbrella
term of Health and Social care or HSC
and similarly reference is made to arm's
length bodies as being HSC bodies
however the department believes that it
is important to note that these terms
are merely colloquialisms and HSC is
used as a shorthand for the Health and
Care Social Health and Social care
system as a whole in Northern Ireland
there has never been an organization
called Health and Social care Northern
Ireland
wild Storm's length bodies are
accountable to the department again it
is emphasized that they are themselves
separate legal entities
in these opening remarks
it is asserted that the Department's
main priority from day one
was the protection of Northern Ireland
citizens from the virus and supporting
efforts to contain the spread of the
virus
excuse me
in giving a very high level overview of
the department state of preparedness it
should be noted that there has been a
clear structure providing a level of
protection and emergency response to the
people of Northern Ireland which was
consistent with elsewhere in the United
Kingdom
the Northern Ireland civil contingencies
framework was first published in 20 2005
following the introduction of the Civil
contingencies act in 2004.
an updated version of the framework was
published in 2011.
this affords Northern Ireland the same
level of protection and emergency
preparedness as elsewhere in the UK
despite the framework not being a
statutory instrument it is implemented
in the same way as if it were
legislation
the framework required the department to
maintain review and update its emergency
response plan
the Department undertakes emergency
preparedness and planning on an ongoing
basis in order to maintain Readiness and
to respond to any emergency with Health
and Social care consequences
as part of the Department's
responsibility for leading the health
response to a pandemic it participated
in uk-wide pandemic influenza planning
as well as participating in working
groups and UK governance structures and
a range of activities to test and
exercise plans
consequently the department has been
able to benefit from Lessons Learned and
revise the Department's emergency
response plan
when the World Health Organization
declared the coronavirus outbreak as a
public health emergency of international
concern in January 2020 it became
rapidly apparent that covid-19 would
challenge the existing emergency
response mechanisms globally as well as
in Northern Ireland
the rapid spread of the virus also
highlighted the importance of
cooperation across UK and further afield
and the sharing of information which the
department carried out with its
counterparts in the Republic of Ireland
the department and its arms-length
bodies activated their emergency
response plans and followed the command
and control structures the systems and
the processes which had previously been
put in place to manage its response
the experience of the pandemic has
highlighted that the timely exchange of
information and coordination of measures
between the devolved administrations to
assist in containing the spread of the
virus was a crucial element for an
effective and a coherent response
undoubtedly the department has benefited
from the dedication of civil servants of
Personnel in arm's length bodies and
from Frontline HSE workers all of whom
worked tirelessly to manage and overcome
the pandemic
nevertheless the department recognizes
that there are lessons to be learned and
hopes that this inquiry will help us
identify those lessons to ensure that it
is better prepared for the future
in this the inquiry's first module the
inquiry's focus will be on preparedness
of amongst others this department and
its ability to scale up its pandemic
plans in order to address the demands
placed on the broader Health and Social
care system
the department has provided evidence to
the inquiry in a range of areas
including how it was able to increase
capacity for diagnosing Laboratory
Testing and procedures for testing and
contact tracing in consequence of the
implementation and adaptation of their
preparedness plans
the department worked closely with
health authorities and government
departments across the UK and Ireland in
a joint effort to significantly
contribute to the general understanding
of how the virus spread in order to
assist in controlling its further spread
and to provide support as necessary
it is also noted that additional funding
was provided from the UK government to
assist in addressing the challenges of
the pandemic
in circumstances such as a pandemic the
inescapable reality is that smaller
administrations such as Northern Ireland
will inevitably need to look to the more
extensive resources in other parts of
the United Kingdom in order to help it
react in a timely way
furthermore we consider it appropriate
to highlight that all of the decisions
required of the default administration
were taken locally on advice from the
Northern Ireland civil service
the pandemic planning and the system
preparedness in Northern Ireland prior
to March 2020 including those
developments and changes which were
implemented during the course of the
pandemic has been detailed in a number
of statements lodged with the inquiry
from our key professionals
we consider that the evidence submitted
by the department has shown how
continuous learning occurred throughout
the pandemic
this learning was in part as a
consequence of increased and invo
evolving scientific understanding of the
virus of its transmission the disease
severity and development and the
Persistence of immunity
throughout these first stages there were
improvements in Northern Ireland's
reaction to the pandemic as a result of
increased availability of testing
improvements in pandemic modeling
improved understanding of individual and
population behaviors and how they were
influenced by modeling and by the
development of vaccines and how their
rapid deployment was affected as well as
by the impact of non-pharmaceutical
interventions
we include in that contact tracing and
isolation
as well as novel therapeutic treatments
these developments were used to inform
policy and appropriate responses
I should also my lady make a brief
remark about the preparations Northern
Ireland had undertaken for a No Deal EU
exit
whilst these preparations did divert
some of our Focus away from pandemic
preparedness planning as was no doubt
the case for all four nations of the
United Kingdom
on the positive side the many aspects of
additional training improvements in the
resilience of Supply chains and the
preparedness to manage the potential
consequences where when considered
overall thought to be advantageous
the benefits included local and Regional
increased buffer stocks and stockpiles
for medicines and medical devices
clinical consumables and the enhanced
multi-agency command and control
training undertaken by all Northern
Ireland departments and multi-agency
responders
these EU exit preparations also helped
to finalize the building of a dedicated
and bespoke departmental Emergency
Operations Center facility and they also
served to clarify processes roles and
responsibilities for emergency responses
within the department
this also had the benefit the of her
meaning that the cohort that the
department had a cohort of recently
trained staff who were able to assist
with the response to the covid-19
pandemic from the outset
while it is fair to say that no one in
Northern Ireland could have reasonably
anticipated the scale of the challenges
caused by the pandemic or indeed
anticipated the steps necessary to
prevent our Health and Social care
system from being overwhelmed
nonetheless there are important lessons
for the future
the department is motivated to ensure
that there is longer term Horizon
scanning to identify future risks in
tandem with actively building future
capacity and capability to identify and
respond to these future risks
undoubtedly managing a pandemic on this
scale is the most significant challenge
for any government and indeed it was
particularly difficult for a newly
formed executive after three years with
new government
in considering the impact that the lack
of an executive in Northern Ireland had
in the Years preceding this pandemic we
have identified several disadvantages
despite this and from the Department's
perspective the exercise of civil
contingencies and pandemic planning
functions was not affected by the
absence of ministers and no policy
matters matters arose during the
three-year period that required specific
consideration by the executive
in conclusion my lady the department
would reiterate that it is very aware of
the far-reaching and devastating impacts
that the pandemic had on all aspects of
society and is acutely conscious of the
enduring consequences that continue to
be experienced by our Health Service
the department also recognizes that the
inquiry is uniquely placed to identify
learnings and recommendations that
should help shape future responses
it is for these reasons that the
department places the utmost importance
on this inquiry
as such the department reiterates its
firm commitment to this inquiry and
stands ready to assist in any way that
it can
given the potential for another pandemic
it is essential that lessons are
identified and fully learned across
Health and Social care and all parts of
government
the department welcomes the opportunity
to provide this opening statement and it
is hoped that this brief overview of the
Health and Social care structure the
systems and processes in Northern
Ireland in relation to pandemic
preparedness has been useful in setting
the same
finally the department wishes again to
convey our deepest sympathies to those
bereaved throughout the course of the
pandemic and those would be our
submissions my lady thank you very much
indeed
no I think it's Mr Ford
[Music]
foreign
behalf of adph the association of
directors of Public Health
and before I briefly explain what the
association is and what its position is
in respect of the issues with with which
this module of the pandemic is concerned
I want to read these words from
Professor Jim McManus who is the
president of the association and who
will be giving evidence in week four
over 225 000 people in the UK Alone lost
their lives to this virus with many
people experiencing the enduring pain of
long cavid and as we have heard many who
have lost loved ones and colleagues and
care and health staff who have
experienced significant trauma our
hearts are with them all
the scale of this lot's loss heightens
considerably the fundamental moral
obligation on all of us to ensure that
when the next pandemic comes as it will
we are absolutely prepared to respond in
a way which delivers the minimum
possible loss of life and harms to
people
keeping faith with those who have lost
have been lost bereaved or harmed
entails that all above all else we lay
seriously to heart this serious shared
obligation to articulate
symptoms as systems structures working
cultures and behaviors which will
deliver that goal
my lady the ad pH is the representative
organization of the directors of Public
Health across the UK
the association is along with the local
government Association and its its
equivalence in the devolved Nations The
only voice of localism that the inquiry
is going to hear in this module
the role of the directors of Public
Health have been likened to that of a
local chief medical officer
their role is similar across the UK
although there are some differences
between the Public Health Systems in
which they operate
as you've heard I think for Mr Keith in
England every local Authority with
public health responsibility must employ
a specialist dph they're jointly
employed by authorities in the dhsc
directors retain the primary
responsibility for the health of their
communities and are accountable for the
delivery of their authorities Public
Health duties
the director is a statutory chief
officer of their local Authority and the
principal advisor on all Health matters
to elected members and officials
in Scotland and Wales directors are
employed by NHS NHS health health boards
while in Northern Ireland the sole dph
is accountable to the chief medical
officer directors are also present in
Crown dependencies and overseas
territories
functioning as both directs of Public
Health and the chief medical officer for
their respective jurisdictions
related the association wants to convey
to the inquiry some key messages about
resilience and preparedness for
pandemics at a local level
I'll summarize those messages now and
they will be expanded on by Professor
McManus when he gives his evidence and
developed later in closing written and
oral submissions
the position of the association is that
there was in the latter part of the
period with which this module of the
inquiry is concerned an insufficient
understanding of the role capabilities
and responsibilities of directs of
Public Health at a national level
and as a consequence they were largely
omitted from the systems processes and
plans that begun to be put in place at
that point
directs of Public Health are trained in
containing infectious diseases
understanding and interpreting data
recognizing risk factors understanding
of the evidence base and what motivates
behavioral change and helping develop
local policy interventions
directors also have a deep knowledge of
their local populations and Community
organizations
while the directors were working at a
local level at the start of the pandemic
they were repeatedly excluded from Key
Communications and guidance developed at
a national level they should have been
consulted earlier and more
comprehensively by national bodies with
responsible for health protection from
the outset
there are some striking examples of this
as you will hear in the evidence
firstly at the start of the pandemic
the Department of Health and Social care
did not hold an up-to-date contact list
for the director of Public Health in the
various local authorities
secondly at the start of the pandemic
directors were learning about new
policies and guidance at the same time
as members of the public were when the
televised 5 PM daily briefings began to
be broadcast
they were expected to implement these
policies without the necessary
structures and support mechanisms having
been put in place
along with several other core
participants
um adph was asked by the inquiry to
Canvas the views of its members which it
did by means of the survey
and the majority of its members felt
that initially there were very limited
routes available to them to engage with
the national approach
and that during those initial stages of
the pandemic it's widely felt that the
local voice was neither wanted nor heard
Ley director of Public Health and their
teams have extensive experience and
understanding of contact tracing
their local communities and The Wider
Health and Social care system
within local government there were
environmental health offices and Public
Health Specialists with the skills to
support contact tracing efforts in
response to the virus however the
involvement of local councils and
directors in the test and Trace service
was at the beginning of the pandemic
very limited
local capacity to carry out testing and
contract tracing was not recognized at a
national level
returning related to the survey
directors were asked what were the top
five factors which most negatively
impacted on their status of Readiness
and these were their responses
One National guidance relating to
pandemic preparedness did not anticipate
the nature of the challenges provided by
covid-19
to full lockdown was never anticipated
as a reasonable worst case scenario so
plans did not reflect the challenges
that such a lockdown
would raise
three inadequate and unclear
communication and support from central
government
for inadequate capacity in the public
health Workforce
and five inadequate funding it is the
view of the association that across the
public health system
funding and Staffing levels have been
run down to such an extent at all levels
that response to the kobit 19 pandemic
was severely hampered
you will know my lady that many of those
five points if not all of them have been
raised by other core participants
already in their opening submissions
directors also identified the issue of
data sharing this was a key challenge in
the early stages of the pandemic the
ability of directors to establish
effective data sharing protocols varied
significantly both across England and
the devolved Nations
statutory data protection requirements
were rightly or wrongly thought to be an
obstacle to data sharing
and different organizations had markedly
different interpretations of their data
protection obligations
although beyond the remit of this model
module it's right to observe that as the
pandemic progressed there were increased
there was increasing recognition of the
value of local leadership as a vital
component of the pandemic response
directors were brought in to provide a
local perspective and inform the design
of the system
they worked at PACE to develop local
outbreak plans ensure the challenges of
kobit 19 were understood and addressed
the impact on local communities but
there were in the view of the
association numerous missed
opportunities early on
the overall Milady the association's
view is that the UK was inadequately
prepared for a pandemic of this nature
at a local level directors working in
partnership with local authorities the
NHS voluntary sectors and other
emergency responders had plans in place
for an influenza pandemic for the
reasons that you've already heard and
did their best to adapt those
arrangements to meet the challenges
presented by covert 19. in future
national and local plans will need to be
more flexible to respond to different
types of viruses and threats
looking forward the association's view
is that much greater local involvement
is needed in formulating National policy
this means bringing bodies together such
as the adhp the local government
Association the associations of
directors of adult and children Social
Services all along with their devolved
equivalence
to combine and inform the national
response
business there needs to be greater
recognition of the role of local public
health and local government in the
planning of future pandemics in the
association's view a key lesson is that
local driven processes and responses are
more speedy and effective than those
prescribed centrally through top-down
approaches and enable improved
coordination and collaboration between
agencies
important that the UK government
understands the distinct role of
directors of Public Health when engaging
locally
lady finally returning to the survey the
directors were asked
to suggest ways for improved in
preparedness and resilience and these
are the 10 top 10 points which they
raised
firstly putting in place arrangements to
enable data and intelligence flow more
freely from National agencies to local
public health teams organizations and
authorities
secondly improved transparency and
timeliness of communications from
national government
thirdly national government should
consider developing a national strategy
around Communications during an
emergency and utilize the voice of
trusted local leaders in the voluntary
sector
fourth conducting regular tests of
preparedness to better equip the
workforce to respond to pandemics by
providing more training opportunities
for Relevant staff in health protection
and pandemic preparedness
fifth widening the scope of emergency
planning to be more inclusive of
different emergencies and diseases in
developing a national testing strategy
early on
6 maintaining the relationships they
form during the pandemic with internal
external Partners through the local
resilience forums
seventh better harnessing of the
voluntary and Community sectors and
emergency planning strategy going
forward eighth grader Clarity around the
role of the directs of Public Health and
local authorities in pandemic
preparedness and emergency planning
ninth greater certainty around the
public health grounds and more funding
for emergency planning and health
protection and 10th expanding the public
health Workforce
well there's the aim of the associate
Association is to provide evidence to
this inquiry that informs better
pandemic planning and preparedness in
summary three lessons
lessons point to three essential themes
firstly improving the overall health of
the UK including reducing Health
inequalities secondly clarifying the
roles and responsibilities of key
agencies and professionals at all levels
and thirdly ensuring sufficient Powers
capacity and resources are in place lady
we must learn these lessons from covert
and we must do better next time
thank you very much thank you very much
indeed Mr Ford
and I think it's now Mr Allen
my lady thank you very much
um it's my privilege to represent the
interests of the local government
Association and the Welsh local
government Association in this so
important process
the two associations work very closely
together and welcome the opportunity to
contribute as co-participants in this
module together they represent the
collected voice of local government
having a hundred percent of the Welsh
and over 99 of the English principal
local authorities as members and these
are of course category one responders
and core members of local resilience
forum
they applied to become core participants
because local government and its
officers played such a major role in
bringing these countries through the
pandemic
there also can be no doubt that local
government would be called on to play
this role again should there ever be
another pandemic and of course it would
do so with total commitment
my lady you will recall that during
lockdown we were encouraged to go out
and bang our saucepans to celebrate and
acknowledge the contribution of key
workers
the predominant media Focus was on those
who worked in the NHS
but the phrase key workers went much
wider
like the NHS nearly all local government
officers were engaged in the pandemic
response
on average only one percent of directly
employed Council staff were furloughed
during 2020
and in numerical terms the role played
by the local Authority Workforce was
comparable to that of the NHS
in our areas in full-time equivalent
terms about a million compared to 1.28
million
it is therefore really important in this
inquiry that you and the wider public
and media appreciate just how big a part
local authorities had in bringing the
country through
political leaders of all parties have
praised local Authority officers for
their dedication and flexibility and so
Business Leaders
so it may be surprising to say but in
this module it will we believe become
clear that the fullest and necessary
understanding of the role of local
government should and could plan the
pandemic was sometimes lacking within
central government
let me summarize now what local
government did and would do again in the
very shortest of terms it can be said
that throughout the pandemic councils
kept essential local Services going
but they did considerably more than that
they stepped up to deliver a whole Suite
of new functions crucial to the response
putting it rather more fully local
government continued to have a major
role in almost all of life's big moments
as well as the everyday Services people
rely on
registering births deaths marriages and
Partnerships protecting consumers
providing social housing safeguarding
children and young people collecting
waste maintaining transport and other
local infrastructure
providing open spaces for health and
Recreation
managing adult social care for the
elderly and those who are otherwise
clinically vulnerable
and of course ensuring that the
continued to be mortaries and cemeteries
at end of life
only very temporally were some of these
functions but by no means all suspended
during the most restricted periods
at the same time
they had many
admin multi multin-pound National
financial assistance schemes for
business
they ensured that those made vulnerable
by the pandemic across the two countries
were identified and protected
they supported local schools to maintain
educational provision and support for
pupils
and they co-delivered test and Trace and
vaccination programs to help control the
spread of the virus
and that is why such a very high
proportion of local Authority offices
were designated as key workers with many
changing roles to deal with the pandemic
the associations emphasized therefore
that in planning for civil contingencies
no other body understands local areas
better than their councils and this has
to be taken fully into account
the highly valued Services they deliver
were absolutely crucial to the covid-19
response
by protecting both lives and livelihoods
and that would be so in another pandemic
and yet
as I've already alluded one concern
particularly affecting the LGA and the
English local authorities
is that too often during the pandemic
central government did not fully
understand the way local government in
England worked and what it could
contribute
on occasions it has seemed as though
there was a lack of trust in local
authorities
even perhaps a misplaced confidence by
central government as to what it could
achieve by itself
now I am glad to say that this was not
evident in the relationship between the
devolve government in Wales and the
Welsh local government Association and
Welsh local authorities
both associations
urged this inquiry to conclude
that in all planning for a future
pandemic there must be a full
recognition of the risks and
responsibilities that local authorities
will face and the contributions that
they can make
and that any planning whether on paper
or in exercises to test resilience that
fails fully to include local government
will always be incomplete
and we expect that by the end of your
inquiry the huge contribution of local
government should be as well known as
that of the NHS
that the personal sacrifice in some
cases the ultimate sacrifice
the constant stress danger to health and
many acts of great courage of local
Authority officers should be fully
understood and better appreciated by you
central government the media and the
public
and that it will be realized in the
future that more engagement by central
government with local government can
only enhance the quality of both
contingency planning and emergency
responses
now this first module focuses on the
steps taken in the period between 2009
and 2020 to prepare for a pandemic
occurring at some time in the
foreseeable future
in the view of both associations that
local government was generally well
prepared for what central government had
expected of councils in dealing with an
influenza pandemic
but that of course is not at the heart
of the module one's questions
and is not to say either the resilience
of Health Protection Systems operated
perfectly
on resilience matters we expect the
inquiry to find
that some guidance was out of date
the central government was not always
willing to share information with local
Partners in a timely way
and in the run-up to 2020 attention was
being diverted to other resilience
issues such as the No Deal EU exit
on health protection issues we expect
the inquiry to find
That central government policy making
was undermined by its lack of
understanding of the public health
system which at a national level was
complex and on occasion fragmented
and we Echo therefore some of the points
already made by the previous speaker
across these points we expect inquiry to
see that all local government services
had been impacted by austerity
this as we've heard has gone on for a
decade
the reductions in funding saw councils
lose 60p out of every pound of funding
and that must be seen against Rising
demand in key services such as adult and
children social care and homelessness
support
inevitably this impacted the ability to
plan to prepare and resource and the
overall resilience of services
notwithstanding my client's witness
statements set out the steps consuls
have taken around risk assessment and
contingency planning and testing and
exercising as well as the engagement by
the two associations themselves
and councils consider that they well
prepared for what was expected of them
you will already know that local
government was not in charge though of
the process of pandemic planning
its engagement was in response to
requests and directions from Central and
evolved government
and it is clear in hindsight that there
were significant gaps in the pandemic
process planning process by central
government
there was insufficient focus on the
emerging infectious diseases such as
MERS and SARS relate a relative to the
engagement on influenza
there was a failure to learn from how
Asian countries were responding to these
diseases
and in any event the learning from
previous incidents and exercises was not
consistently applied
perhaps most seriously of all none of
the pandemic plans suggested
non-pharmaceutical interventions such as
National lockdowns international travel
restrictions
wholesale school and workplace closures
or compulsory quarantine
in no significant way was there any
preparation for these meaning that when
the pandemic struck new plans had to be
developed from scratch
it will be obvious in general terms and
this will no doubt be discussed later in
module 2 in more specific terms
that to make these mpis work swiftly
efficiently and effectively required
close local knowledge and support
the failure to Think Through fully how
the rate of infection would have to be
controlled during a pandemic was
therefore a very significant emission
it became a matter of political dispute
when it ought to have been a matter of
social planning well in advance
the association say that if it had been
considered in vance
those difficult issues that had to be
considered in the pandemic that is to
say effective subsidiarity business
continuity
human rights and the disproportionate
impacts on minorities could have been
thought through and addressed in karma
times
and when these matters were addressed
the skills that already resided within
local government could have been engaged
much more quickly and dynamically
the lack of planning for these measures
was subsequently compounded by an
initial failure to recognize the vital
role local governments should play when
systems were designed
for instance instead of developing from
scratch a new test and Trace system the
skills of the directors of Public Health
in England and the directors of public
protection in Wales could have been
harnessed at the outset
how will this could have been done
better in advance is of course the
complex question for you in this module
as the events of 2020 to 2022 have shown
pandemics are complex social and
behavioral challenges and not just
technocratic issues
so I want to make it clear that the
approach of the two associations I
represent is by no means a purely
negative and critical one
local government does not say that
everything was wrong
it recognizes that there were also many
positives about a system with the
capability and Agility to quickly pivot
from existing plans to respond to the
pandemic
but it also says that these systems can
and should be improved with local
government treated as an equal partner
in this
and the association's hope that this too
will form part of your conclusions
my lady I want to move now to set out
some summary points that the local
government associations will be asking
you to have in your recommendations and
I take them first from the evidence to
be given by the chief executive of the
local government Association Mark Lloyd
one improved Democratic engagement with
local resilience forums
two Amendment of the Civil contingencies
act and delegated legislation to ensure
it's more aligned to the issue of
resilience
three specific obligations on central
government on sharing critical planning
information with local government
4. much greater emphasis on the
importance of preparing for the
implications for social care in the
context of a pandemic
five greater discussion of Health
protection in the preparations of a
pandemic including all forms of MPI and
their different consequences for
breaking infections while maintaining
business continuity in Civil Society
six greater understanding of the
different roles of Health protection
obligations of councils and the more
General role of local resilience forum
seven
a better collection of guidance
information into one place
eight less secrecy in Risk assessments
nine greater focus on local issues in
Risk assessments
10. more systematized account of
protected characteristics in emergency
plans
11 more work on public awareness
campaigns
12 distinct data sharing plans to enable
local government to act effectively and
swiftly for instance in identifying
vulnerable persons
and 13 more General planning for
and Mr Luellen Chris Llewellyn the chief
executive of the Welsh local government
Association mentions many of the same
issues but I would add to the previous
list from his witness statement the
following
one that there should be protocols and
agreements for consistent
intergovernmental planning and
co-decision making on a pan UK scale as
part of the Devolution settlement
two
Advanced planning is necessary for Welsh
local authorities having to manage
different approaches being taken by the
devolved and Central governments so as
to avoid the confusion and tensions that
can occur in cross-border areas
three linking closely with the lga's
third point there must be a much better
and Fuller direct interaction between
central government and Welsh local
authorities where policy directions are
uk-wide not evolved so as to enable
immediate and consistent responsive
action at the local level
four contingency arrangements are needed
for the Urgent deployment of pre-trained
and appropriately skilled officers into
emergency command and advisory roles
and this should include civil servants
in the UK and Welsh government and also
local government and emergency officers
within local resilience for our
Partnerships and local government
structures
five contingency arrangements are also
necessary for the passing of immediate
and comprehensive legislation and
Guidance with draft modular laws and
stats transmits and guidance held in
Reserve at both the UK and Welsh levels
six there's a need for reserves Cox at
scale and for robust Supply chains for
the provision of specialist medical
equipment and goods such as PPE
with specification specifications
reviewed regularly to ensure
compatibility for emerging viruses
seven resilient emergency planning is
necessary for the expansion of the NHS
facilities and services
to be able to co-manage the demands of a
pandemic alongside critical and
life-saving NHS services not related to
the pandemic
eight Reserve capacity public sector
Workforce redeployment plans and
logistical support and call on contracts
are necessary to stand up key support
services such as mass testing test and
Trace and mass vaccinations
nine there should be plans resources and
flexibilities for the full recovery of
Public Services which might not be able
to resume in meeting their statutory
performance standards and targets for
some time post pandemic
10 Again related to the above LGA 0.11
communication plans are necessary where
there are differences of legal or
administrative approach and these should
be planned for in advance
and 11 also like point 10 in the LGA the
Welsh local government Association
emphasizes the need for a more
systematized approach to taking account
of protected characteristics in
emergency plans
12. the Welsh government should have
more freedom in deciding its Reserve
levels for local authorities and the
overall provision for greater emergency
funding is essential if other services
are not to be cut back
and lastly 13. there should be specific
planning undertaken for the procurement
of medical equipment for use within
Wales
we thank you for this opportunity to
make an opening statement and the two
associations will support you in your
work in every way we possibly can thank
you thank you very much indeed Mr Allen
and we were meant to I think
go to Mr Bull now
um Mr Paul where are you
I'm just wondering can are you here
tomorrow in any event
or would you prefer to go now I don't
mind my lady I'm here tomorrow
whatever's easier
we do have now fortuitously a certain
degree of flexibility tomorrow morning
if if my lady wished to go if you don't
mind Mr I think it's been a long day for
quite a lot of people so if that's all
right with you of course
very well well start at 10 o'clock
tomorrow please with Mr Bull thank you
very much indeed and I hope that
everyone's been okay today
foreign